Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, welcome in, welcome
in.
Hi.
Feeling okay.
I'm okay.
But I didn't want to push this off anymore, so.
I don't want to push this off anymore.
So, today we finish a Bioshock today, today, today.
We will finish a Bioshock today, today, today.
Yeah!
I sound different today.
I do?
How do I sound different?
I don't think I sound different.
The end of an era of technical...
problems yeah oh yes today is the final time that we deal
with the bioshock double cursor yeah today look i can make
them connect though oh oh close why is the one in game
slower than the one on my desktop that's curious hello minto
and ivosaki on 17 months thank you Thank you!
Yay!
DPI diff.
What if our cursor is touched?
Wait, oh, oh, there it is.
Yeah!
Minto cursor is like, yeah, stay away from me!
Yes, finally we will, we will, this is the end of it, maybe,
so.
Let's just hope it goes smoothly today.
And if it He doesn't!
Well...
It's a demo cursor touch.
I will let you know if you play the second one, the cursor
problem is still a thing.
But I tried controller and it works flawlessly.
Oh, it's frozen and get on the screen.
Why is it every time I start the stream, it's frozen?
Why?
YouTube why?
I don't know.
I feel like controller for this game.
Seems so difficult now.
Maybe.
Cold as ice.
Chat's been freaky for everyone.
Yeah, I know.
YouTube.
Why?
YouTube why?
Do you think it's intentional?
Do you guys use, do you guys know the app line?
Like it's a, it's a messaging app, like similar to WhatsApp
or whatever, you know.
But I use Line to talk to a lot of my friends because I love
the stickers on there.
Sure, sir, Jalistan, welcome to Pembo Ship, thank you.
I really like Line.
But recently, like it was so good until recently, like, they
tried to add some new feature and it just has completely
broken the app.
And I'm like, isn't there a saying for this?
Isn't there literally a saying for this that if it's not
broken, don't fix it!
Why?
Why do all these places think that they must do more?
Sometimes we just like the simple thing that it is.
an app it's so funny too because like so basically i'll be
like la la la texting my friends it's all fine everything's
good messaging them everything's going through and then
friday hits friday hits and it seems like they push
something new out and it breaks basically every friday
it uh yesterday i was like huh i'm noticing a pattern here
perhaps it's friday ruin it got the whole weekend to suffer
um yes i'm noticing a pattern and maybe maybe when the devs
the devs are like oh yeah we got to get this code out or
something who knows who knows hi mint hello welcome i hope
you guys are having a good weekend though i haven't really
done much i did some work that i needed to i've been i've
been every day has just been catch up on work that uh that
uh i've when i was gone that i just needed to catch up on,
but luckily, no mustard.
You just woke up!
Good morning?
That's good to hear.
Yeah, I've been, I've been, it's been, uh, busy, busy,
but...
Having a good weekend, now you're here to ruin it.
Yeah!
Guys!
I'm too excited for my next outfit.
I want to show you so bad.
I think it's so cute.
My cutest...
The cutest that I've been, I think, maybe.
I'm so excited.
But I can't show you.
Until it's done.
A couple months from now, maybe even.
Dang it.
No, Eric, you've been sick!
Feel better!
Beep!
I got a dentist so you can see me and great techie!
I'll show you a blink!
Can't wait to meet you and the rest of the girls.
Thank you!
We did our first together meet and greet at WeebCon.
And we really liked it.
So I'm excited to see Mita more than she, all three of us
together.
You seem a little hyper today.
Oh, do I?
I'm actually so tired.
I have to make up for my tiredness.
See, I don't want you guys to think or know that I'm tired
or not feeling good.
So I have to be like a little extra.
To make up for it.
You know what I mean?
I have to be extra.
Extra...
Excitable.
But also I just get excitable when I talk to you guys.
Is that fun?
I missed my own shot at a ticket.
They literally sold out in 40... Wait, they're sold out!
Nothing quite.
Thank you so much for the thought.
Wait, I didn't know they sold out.
Actually, I didn't know they went up.
I didn't know they sold out.
Wait!
No!
people who got it.
Yay!
Thank you!
I wish I could do like meet and greet all day so I could
have like 10 minutes with people.
You know what I mean?
I could have 10 minutes with people and then we could just
talk and not feel rushed.
Meet and greet kingdom.
Don't call it that.
Always support.
That's not my name.
Who is that?
I learned one minute meet and greets are so short.
They're way too short.
Because you know what sucks is when you're waiting on food
in the microwave, one minute feels like forever.
But when you're talking to your Oshi, one minute feels like
a flash.
I hate that.
True.
Especially with three people?
No.
No, it'll be so, it'll be...
Actually, it'll seem longer because it's three people.
Because meet and greet streamer.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It'll seem longer because more people will be talking.
So it'll be like, oh wow, we had such a...
we had so much to say so much conversation was had
everything was great one minute of meat one minute of greet
and now how are we spelling meat m-e-e-t or m-e-a-t are we
having one minute of meat or normal meat and great
experience hi, bye
meat and great imagine a meat and great well I did have a
spit and great one time so I feel like a meat and great what
have I made what have I made skewers and then I gave you one
wait I don't know how to make skewers you might get food
poisoning would that be okay though but what if i what if i
just wait that would be so fun if i made like a shish kebab
wait is that the right word what's a shish kebab if i made
uh about uh uh uh the ones with that would be cool you could
have i could moe moe kum bless your your your meat I say?
What is your wisdom of the day?
Properly cook your meat.
So you don't get food poisoning.
Food poisoned ibis.
No, no, no.
Konbanwa, mito!
I had a dream about attending a meet and greet, dragging my
friend who was into VTubers and making them an ibu.
Then we took a bald selfie together.
Maybe next year, still too short.
No!
Phil?
What if I come to your continent?
I would gladly get food poisoning from my Oishi.
All the iBus.
Say, imagine like, like Afkai, we did a meet and greet and I
gave you all the skewers and then, and then every, every
iBus had food poisoning at the concert.
That would be terrible.
It would be like that one, you know, like don't drink the
Kool-Aid, they'd be like, don't eat mince meat.
It would be...
Not to make light of a tragedy or anything, but you...
Mince Town.
The Mince Town incident.
Mito and greet KBBQ party.
Whee!
That sounds awesome!
Another regular pass, so I had to wait till 10 a.m.
as soon as I logged in, all density tickets were gone.
Hopefully the concert will be available to all...
It will!
Ghost of Min, I'm sorry.
Thank you for trying.
I...
Oh, uh, uh, uh, uh, we...
We're talking about the set list for the concert earlier.
Hehehehe.
Yeah.
Invite me!
Invite me?
Food poisoning before she crills us herself.
No, that's literally how I will do it.
I will kill you myself.
Here, take some meat.
No meat though allowed.
You can't stop me if I'm on an iPad.
What are you gonna do?
me what are you gonna do cut off the wi-fi i want i want you
to shove meat all over my face so it looks like i'm a
barbecue sauce baby you know and babies have barbecue sauce
all over their faces it's like uh-oh baby got into the
barbecue sauce you know feed the baby that was a sentence
sounds like a cult but i've got nothing else on
babyq sauce oh i want some barbecue wait i guess kbbq isn't
like a traditional barbecue sauce huh what is there go have
you guys had kbbq before So you take my favorite thing to do
is you take the lettuce and then you put you put you put the
rice on the lettuce and then the meat But my favorite sauce
to dip the meat in is
Sesame Yes, and then And that is delicious Sesame sauce is
so good.
Yes, that's the good stuff agree Sessamine oil Oh so Yummy
I thought she was about to say Catch up Why would I say
ketchup It does make you kind of wonder that Why is this
ketchup on burgers You don't really take like Say you have
just the Burg of the burger No Ur, just Berg.
Hamburg.
Good evening, Mint.
Don't tell Mata I'm here.
Mug sneaky Momo.
Not the Momo.
Hello, lost Momo.
Just Berg.
You don't dip that in ketchup, you know what I mean?
So like, what if I put sesame oil on my burger instead?
I've been really into like truffle oil on fries lately.
I almost said frogs.
I don't know why.
On fries.
Two years already!
Thank you!
GG, thank you!
I just woke up now, I'm hungry.
Gonna go get some chicken nuggets.
Make sure they're dinosaur shit.
Den sets a EXE concert and barbecue while you three sing
Umaymono Fan Club from Nijikan.
Meow!
Frogs.
I don't think frogs are high taste, no?
Two years.
Thank you!
Nobody tell her truffles or shrooms.
I know.
I know they are.
I think I would like mushrooms if it wasn't for the texture.
I can't handle the texture of the mushroom.
But I like the taste, I think, probably.
You put ketchup on burgers because the grass...
mint patty is structurally related to meatloaf which you
glaze with ketchup in its tradition is that true i struggle
with texture as well yeah but i did go to what was it um i'm
going to order everything well done until i'm until after
the concert is over thanks for making me paranoid i'm always
i'm always in the kitchen
I'm up anywhere, any place you go with a burger, I'll
possess the cook.
What was I saying?
Oh, I went to Hot Pot with Bebue once.
And Bebue was like, I promise you the mushrooms are yummy!
And I tried them and they were pretty good.
I think it's just certain mushrooms, then.
The trick is to have more cheese than mushrooms.
Very healthy choices.
I woke up this morning and my throat was swollen so I'm
trying to drink a lot of water It doesn't hurt Well no
that's a lie It's not a horse Nay It just hurts
It's about to say as someone who's been to Japan you should
have access to quality mushroom Yeah, but I'm scared to eat
to eat.
Did I get a hair tie?
No.
Oh, I have them in my hair.
Duh.
Hydrate.
I am hydrating.
I have a Yuzu honey tea that I am drinking today.
And I recommend everybody else to have some too.
Thanks, Jay.
Did you know there's a perfume brand called Phantom and they
have a perfume called Ectoplasm?
I was a marshmallow-y scent which I really like no way wait
I'm looking it up right now
oh a phantom perfume whoa current processing time is up to
four weeks.
It's kind of long.
Wait, how do I find...
Is it the Spirit Collection?
Ectoplasm!
Extrate de-parfume!
Wow.
Let's see.
What are the notes?
I don't know anything about notes.
Spooky goopy marshmallow over bone-chilling white musk,
sweet amber, uh...
Gossamer, sugar glaze, dark myrrh, and creeping greenery.
Wow.
I think that's what I smell like.
Creeping greenery?
Wait, that might actually be me.
That might be a great...
That midfeller, you know.
She's just creeping greenery.
Greenery.
wait a second
I think I have to buy this whoa wow we I just saw the price
holy moly jay oh sorry I was looking at the 50 milliliter
whoa geez the 50 milliliter is $75 okay wait 10 milliliters
so small no I guess is that a oh no it's just a spritz wait
that's so expensive why is perfume so expensive I've always
wondered that I only I always use like so little you know
like like I use perfume but I do like you know what I mean
so it's like never it lasts me a really really long time but
it is so expensive huh i guess maybe that's why so that it
lasts but there's like always like that first hurdle to to
buy it because even if it does last a long time i'm like man
that price though one of those luxury things yeah i mean a
good perfume though is really good.
You know, I feel like a good perfume is really worth it for
anybody.
Because smelling good is a number one priority.
When I hug somebody and they smell good, I'm like
it's like my most important thing.
I do be sniffing people.
And then sometimes, you know, everybody has that moment when
a lady like walks into an elevator and you smell her and
you're like,
You know?
Or like, or somebody walks out, like the lady walks out of
the elevator and you're like, oh my god, it smells like her
in there.
And you're like, wow.
Mito, that's just you?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I love, I, I, smells like one of my number one things, uh,
you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I will.
I'll be like.
Smell good.
Good smell.
That is very reasonable.
Thank you.
Well, I will think about it.
Oh my gosh, it's even spelled exactly like my last name.
That's crazy.
Phantom.
This perfume place.
Pricy.
I sniffed too loudly and I've gotten dirty looks before.
But in that case, just pretend that you're sniffing.
What, like, you're like, oh, I gotta clear my nose.
Or my nose is dripping.
And just do it really deep.
The perfume was even more expensive when converted and plus
shipping, but it was worth it.
Yay!
Jay, are you going to go to Smash?
The con?
I'm not asking.
I'm not asking anything.
Let's just take a shower to smell good.
If I smell cologne or perfume, I assume that person didn't
bathe.
Really?
I never think that.
But if you...
Jay, I'm asking if you are going because then...
Then...
You can't just ask Samito.
Blame the con!
Why is the convention...
name called smash hey you you you want to go to smash sadly
i live in the west and not in the east no i was gonna say
you should wear it to a meet green i
would smell it on you first and then i would buy it
is that why it's called super smash bros
yeah Whoa.
The other way around.
Doggy style?
I've got to beat Bioshock today.
Let's go.
Um, where were we?
We were in that kind of, uh...
This last place was a little...
Uh...
I remember getting beat up by the camera a lot.
Oh gosh.
have to remember how to play the game.
Okay.
Let's remember.
Hi, Mito.
Hello.
Last level.
Is it truly?
Oh my gosh.
You undid the mental thingies and ever-changing plasmids.
Yeah, I was freaking out going through.
My hands were going through puberty over and over and over
again.
It was actually really terrible.
So we stopped that.
And we...
Um...
But I remember this area...
I think I died.
I don't remember what to.
I died because I was like just running around being in goofy
pants.
But...
What style?
Uh...
Minto style.
Trickster, Royal Guard, Doggy.
Doggy dog.
How to play.
sometimes something with pipes and also sometimes shooting
let's let's continue and i don't remember how to play
probably maybe maybe cute black hair minto yeah she shows up
sometimes oh yes i remember
is there a guy in there no okay i do hear the cameras, but I
don't remember if I tricked them, if I hacked them or not, I
can't remember.
But, um, all right, hold on.
Cigarettes, cigarettes, cigarettes.
Is this thing, is that thing down there?
Is that on?
I think it is.
I think I see it beeping.
All right, all right, hold on.
Wait, how do I get to the...
There we, no, how do I get to the man?
Oh, okay, thanks.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, I died to a turret.
Probably was that one.
Randru.
To the Circus of Values.
I don't think I need anything here.
Maybe the first aid kit.
Maybe.
All right, we have our fire.
We killed that guy.
Oh, that's right.
Um, we're killing big daddies for, uh, they have something.
Wait, oh gosh, how do I see what my, what my goal was?
Okay, also.
M for map?
You are so right.
Wait, is it hint?
I have no goal.
That's not true.
Wait, I can't go up too far.
There we go.
Okay, we haven't gone in this area yet.
But there was something in here, no?
Fire can melt the ice near you.
Oh, you're right!
What's in there?
Wait, am I gonna get burned by that?
You need to find gatherer pheromone samples.
Oh my gosh.
He sounds so close to me.
Like, he sounds right next to me, you know?
So freaking me out.
Is this thing going to burn me, though?
Okay, let's not go towards that guy.
Alright, hold on.
Okay, this one is bad.
This one we did not do.
I forgot to save.
You know what?
It's fine.
We just...
Oh my god, please.
We came back to life, so...
Oh, shoot.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
no no no no oh no wait this is bad everything will kill me
uh that's fine
it's dunzo what oh oh this is dunzo this is so lame
they're hacking
i think this is when they truly are like hey um buddy you
want to get one of those uh Ah!
Sorry, my thing will click out of the game sometimes.
I'm gonna be like, I want to get one of those sick upgrades
to hacking.
You know?
Stupid head.
The thing that you should have bought like a long ass time
ago.
But you're too stubborn to get it.
Please, one more long boy.
No!
I think I could have.
Maybe saved the...
How do I...
Oh my god.
Okay, maybe.
Oh shoot.
Wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Please, please, please, please.
No, I need one that goes down!
Like that.
Yes, yes.
And then, uh, over.
And then, uh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
I'm clicking out of the game.
Um...
I don't have one that goes this way.
I think we're dead.
regardless though.
I have to click really fast.
Ah!
You sucker!
No!
Zawardo!
We are so close!
So stinking close!
Remember when you should have bought those upgrades?
Streamer!
You idiot head.
You stupid stupid.
Uh, uh, I don't think I have the right tools here.
Nope.
Oh my god!
Please let me hack you!
Wait.
Was that it getting mad at me?
I'm auto-hacking it?
It's not mad at me anymore?
I don't know if it was mad at me or not, but uh, it sure
ain't now.
Is this a door?
Open up?
What's this do?
Find the voice box modification.
Nantuckah, nantuckah, nantuckah.
Okay, anyway.
Oh, sh- oh gosh.
Bituber-y.
Shock the door?
Oh, will that work?
Oh!
Oh.
There's a lot going on in here.
What is going on in here?
Holy kill.
Bot shut down something something.
Coffee and potato chips?
Potato chips?
I guess I didn't really need to eat those, but whatever.
Beep boops are happening in here.
I have to get used to the game again, you guys.
Temporary generator override.
It does say temporary.
How long does it... Oh, look at that.
Wait, can I...
Why don't I just telekinesis those?
Oh!
No, come back.
Pick up.
Oh, pick up.
Oh, it's a...
It's a safe, I just noticed.
Oh my god.
It lasts quite a while.
Oh.
Until it doesn't.
Oh, now it's half.
Or it's like a quarter.
Left.
But getting in there.
I don't even know how.
Brian.
Andrew.
Whoa, whoa.
That's not me.
Smart Oshi.
Well, we got that at least.
we can save the um the save for later maybe i don't have any
more auto hacks just in case because those ones those ones
are really hard now i think i think i need uh what's it
called to to do it you know what i mean randrew why is it
always ryan you're telling me all right let's go in here
Test?
Subject tested.
I hear somebody.
Country roots.
Why is she sounds so close?
Where is she?
Is there anything in here?
Oh.
It's too bright for you.
Take your money, though.
Looks like my cat.
And she's like, oh, it's too bright.
Please turn off the lights.
She's in the walls.
I think actually.
Candidate induction.
Live subject control room.
She must be there.
I'm getting scared from this game again.
Because it's been a minute since I last played.
You know what I mean?
Oh, I hear.
What is that?
What was that?
It's quiet.
Too quiet.
Yeah.
No, I don't want the cigarettes.
Oh, uh, what can we make here?
trap vault no maybe uh heat seeking rpg is pretty good just
a fish drinking alcohol restores yeah yeah the armor
piercing auto rounds honestly we need more of those because
um because of big daddy Oh, I didn't even realize you could!
Oh, shoot.
My bad.
Uh, let's attack it.
Save.
Yeah.
Good for big deities.
We gotta, we gotta get more of him because...
Oh, it's this one.
Okay.
Uh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Oh, it's so fast.
It's so freaking fast!
Ah!
It'll eat it'll eat it'll eat it'll eat it's so this one is
really fast it's tough it's a tough Oh yes I love when the
game loves me
Well shoot let's see I have so much supplies you know
honestly it's like why don't I make so much more stuff you
know I have so much supplies Automatic hack tool!
We'll make two of those.
Doesn't love you that much, unfortunately.
No, she loves me!
She loves me!
Go go gadget me!
He's seeking RPG.
We'll make two.
I don't even know how much of these I have, you know.
I use like everything.
Oh.
Oh, I don't know.
I can't even, I made them and I can't even use them.
Well, shoot.
That's my bad.
Boy, oh, this is the voice box.
Oh my gosh, we're going to really turn into him.
Oh my gosh.
Someone's behind there.
They look like grenades, though.
They're kind of scared me.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
No more talking.
I don't think I did that much talking anyway.
oh I can't oh I can't do any more napalm all right bottle it
on the cabinet this oh thank you here we go one down two
steps to go now you need only to be finding the body suit
and the pheromones from the other lab what you wait for
engraved invitation Oh, oh, this guy.
Are your hacks still being interrupted by alarms?
Then you need alarm expert 2 today.
Yeah.
But I don't have a store.
What is this?
Hacking expert.
Four fewer alarms.
Oh, wait.
No, this is four fewer alarms.
Okay.
Very cool.
Did I search that?
Yeah, okay.
Okay.
Holy cow!
Holy moly, it scared the heck out of me.
I should have known it would happen, but...
It scared me.
Oh, man, it scared me.
It scared me good.
Where'd they come from?
Give me your money.
And your pet bars.
You need the...
find gatherer pheromones.
Okay, okay, okay, I got it, I got it, I got it.
Are there any...
Did I... did I do that?
I think so.
Did I do that?
All the other body is in here.
We're in here before.
Baby, baby, baby, baby.
No?
Who took your baby?
Wait, uh... Oh, shoot.
I think I got her.
Noice.
Are you the one that took my baby?
Oh, I thought that was a body.
Oh my gosh.
Hold on one second.
I gotta like fix my...
I gotta...
I'm gonna move my mouse over there.
Okay.
You burned her baby.
I'm the baby.
I don't know.
what happened about baby.
I know nothing.
I'm not a babysitter.
I know nothing of the babies.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, yeah.
We're like, I cannot believe we're actually turning into...
Why am I so short?
We're turning into Big Daddy.
I'm going to be the shortest Big Daddy ever.
Why is the sink so tall?
Oh, it's because I'm the baby.
Bottom left, baby.
Baby, bottom left?
I know what you are.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run, run, run.
Oh, shoot.
Uh, sorry.
I was just gonna save before I try to hack it.
La la la la la la.
Oh, shoot.
Why are you so fast?
Uh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay, nice, nice.
Not nice.
La, la, la.
Please.
No.
I guess I could have gone up in a rap.
I could have saved it, I think.
That's my fault.
I think that's my fault.
I was too slow to realize.
Oh my goodness, where are the pieces that I need?
Here we go.
There we go.
Thank you.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's okay.
Maybe?
Maybe.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Well handled, thank you.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, it's this guy again.
I will lock them up near the protector labs and set the code
to 1921.
1921!
I don't expect we'll ever be needing them, though.
Once Big Daddy is ready, nobody crossed the Big Daddy.
Wait, so he put of where?
I didn't quite catch that part.
He put hoo-ha-hoo.
What, what, what?
Gather a fair room.
Is there anything in here?
A whole lot of nothing?
Maybe?
Nobody crushes the big daddy.
Except me, baby.
Oh, wait.
I wonder if this is... Wait, also.
Fonteid!
No,
this is impossible!
Impossible run!
I should have... It was impossible from the start.
Ah.
Oh.
Bro just keeps yapping.
I know, I just let him do his thing.
I don't listen to him anymore.
He's just gonna say what he wants to say.
Shoot, I don't want to use...
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Please, please.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes.
I like when they're easy.
Okay.
All right, sorry.
Let's save again.
Ta-da!
What's he happen about?
Okay.
Someone in here?
Someone in there.
Oh, shoot.
I'll do it again.
Wait, is she just dying in there?
What is she doing?
I think she's dying in there.
I can't check on her because it's on fire.
Oh shoot, I missed.
How could I miss?
Oh, lady!
Probably should stop using this, though.
Sort of like that.
Anyway.
Ah!
Thank you?
Oh, it's this room.
Wait, wait, wait, why?
Why?
Oh, shoot.
Wait, no.
I promise.
Why did you come after me?
Wait, what's this?
Oh, shoot.
There's cash in there.
Please go down.
Where's the thing to turn it off?
Where do I turn you off?
How do I turn you off?
off?
How do I turn it off?
Wait, I'm safe in here.
Okay.
We're fine, we're fine.
Everything's fine.
Oh, oh, oh, scared me.
Stand still, you go invisible?
I do.
You're so right.
Wait, I want to know what got me where'd this come from oh
it's gone now um oh let's go get that money that i saw
earlier plasmid pro typing how do i crouch there we go two
dollars worth maybe i think rapture is pretty nice
Fontaine!
Ryan!
Maybe...
Okay, never mind.
It sucks here.
I was cooking and had Streamon in the background.
Those sounds were something?
What?
The lady?
The lady in the room going...
That one?
Everything was nice before Fontaine.
Now this guy is dukey.
Okay, let's not go into the backup generator.
go in here wait the paradise hates three things free markets
free will and free man what is this angel why is it upside
down okay i saw the thing hold on let's save real quick i
saw the thing i have to disarm my crossbow does have zoom i
don't remember how to use it what is it uh i don't remember
how to use it though.
Oh, there's two of them?
Z?
Oh, thank you guys.
Thank you so much.
You guys are so helpful.
I really appreciate it.
There's one.
I wonder if I can get them.
Oh, no!
My game clicked out.
What the hell?
Why did it come at me?
Wait, why did it come back at me?
What was that?
Oh, it was the rip oh shoot wait um how do i uh how do i
switch wait hold on i don't remember oh my gosh why am i so
stupid with this game now all of a sudden well i'm not all
of a sudden there we go okay thank you we'll grab them this
person before we go to get the before the turrets can kill
us like me
you for like two seconds please oh you oh oh but they might
have realized that someone's shooting at them
I need your pheromones okay
maybe I just saved so we'll do plan B instead which is uh
attempting exactly
that was my plan Exactly that was my plan.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
And thank you both.
What do we have?
The gene bank!
I want another thing for hacking.
Hacking is too tough now.
It actually, like I liked the challenge before, but now it's
actually too tough a little bit, you know?
So...
Thank you.
I said nothing.
Weapon upgrade!
Let's do my pistol!
Oh.
I hope I did my pistol.
I think I did.
More like too unfair.
Yeah!
Oh!
Nice!
I get it back!
Yeah, it has become very unfair.
Not unfair.
Yeah, maybe a little unfair.
I wish I could bring him in here.
I wonder if I can lead him in here, you know.
I'm, let's, let's, these ones are impossible, though.
I don't think it's even possible.
I don't think this is even possible.
Oh my god.
Oh, look how fast it is.
No.
That's no, that's not even, that's not possible.
That ain't possible.
It ain't possible.
I wonder if I can loot.
What the hell?
Did she just jump in the water?
I'll get her again.
Wait, can I take a picture of you on fire?
Action photo.
No.
I don't want to get burned by you, though.
Oh, I- oh yeah, you're napalm.
Napalm, erra?
Oh, come on, please.
There's a second guy!
Of course there was!
Is he coming out, too?
Oh.
Something's exploding.
Wait, what's going on?
I scared you, my bud.
Oops.
I should have reloaded.
Oh.
We're going in.
Guns are blazing.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Don't even worry your pretty little head about it.
Well, do you think all these things do in here, huh?
What do you wonder?
What is exploding?
I gotta go see.
Yeah, we chilling.
Use the grenade.
I like shooting.
Is it in here?
No, it's this one.
Oh, there are just guys in here, aren't they?
Where'd they come from?
good job good job what are they doing in here you just one
guy all
this commotion for one one little male okay oh I feel like I
feel like my cursor issue is getting worse and worse huh
guys where are these guys coming from anyway they're the
gasoline too.
Oh.
They're just laying in there every time.
I'll take it.
Oh, searched.
Like, is there a new guy in here?
There is!
Where is he?
Where'd he go?
I saw him.
Not crazy.
Oh, I think he left out there.
I'll wait You made me drop my sandwich I'm sorry I finished
with the Ivo decoration mod for retro rewind Thank you!
It's on Nexus mods Gonna work on adding some fun community
movie titles today Thank you so much!
Thank you Oh Okay
We got him though
My cursor.
I feel like it really is getting worse.
Randall!
For sight when he built up the plasmid business.
But the man really never understood sales.
Hiding those little girls beneath a bushel.
I've just seen the preliminary design work on the new
plasmid machines.
Can I get my bolt back?
Did I get it back?
Mark my words.
Presented properly.
Those little sisters are marketing gold.
Yes!
Little sisters are marketing gold.
So true.
Oh, whoops, that's not what I meant to click.
Can't see me.
Stupid.
They can't see me.
Wait, that would be...
learning how to play the game, the end of the game.
What if I, like, stand still and go invisible and take
photos?
That's the great thing about the invisible thing is it
happens so fast.
Like, it's almost immediate.
You know?
You go invisible, like, so quickly.
Anybody in here?
Oh.
I heard a camera.
Also, these feel like they should be for something?
But it doesn't It seemed like it.
All right, hold on, I'm sorry.
Ranju Renu.
When you're with me, don't take you!
Thank you, Grizzly!
Oh, there's something here.
All right, let's...
It was...
Oh, hello.
Don't come this way.
Scabby on my knee.
Oh, no.
Wait, is that money?
No, I think that's a health kit.
Excuse me, go away please.
Thank you.
Except I think I need to kill him.
Oh wait, maybe the camera I'm hearing is outside.
Oh, oops.
It's fine, I got it down.
I got it down still, whatever.
Not the scabby, scabby on my knee, scabby on my knee.
That's me right now.
I don't know why.
I have so many...
Not scabbies.
My knees are all busted, I think, from the idol show.
Oh,
I can't take that anymore.
I think...
We need to...
Actually, I don't even remember how...
Oh, wait.
The grenades...
Okay, or this.
Yeah, that's right.
Okay.
going too crazy for my ohshi you guys never get on your
knees for your ohshi
that like they just they just bring you to your knees
because you are so overwhelmed by how amazing they are i'm
on my knees right now get up get up king what are you doing
They're honorable battle scars.
Yeah, but they're not real cute, maybe.
Alright.
I can't tell.
Oh, shoot.
Alright, I think if I'm, like, right underneath it, I can't
see me, right?
But just in case.
Oh my gosh.
Click.
Please stop.
Again, I know you're gonna...
I just want to save.
There we go.
Okay.
I'm just trying to save.
What?
we'd have to kneel down to talk to face-to-face boss no you
wouldn't you wouldn't you oh no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no okay maybe salvageable probably not
probably not probably not probably not probably not oh shoot
oh shoot oh shoot oh shoot oh shoot oh shoot oh shoot oh
wait okay let's see how if we can salvage this we can use
this and this we might be able to salvage this
yes cheating it's not cheating if the game is actively
trying to sabotage me journey welcome back thank you holy
cow that was crazy save our the same one I just did.
Yes!
Yeah, the game cheats too.
Yeah, so true.
Okay, so I'm guessing we might have to...
Is there a guy in the middle here?
It's three too many.
I can't tell if the person lying there is dead or because of
me or, you know.
Okay, wait.
If I attack him, I could lead him into there and then let
the maybe both you know I do need to keep killing some of
these guys right that's why I'm kind of like hmm I did just
save oh that was scary run
oh my god I'm stuck wait He's coming in, right?
Oh, shoot.
Okay, they're trying.
You got this?
Oh,
he's so close to dying.
Holy shit, please.
Bees.
Oh.
Where did this guy come from?
Uh, rescue you?
No!
Holy cow!
Where did that guy come from?
What can I really do for these little ones?
I am haunted by sins.
Oh, I guess I don't need them.
Perhaps you unlock a future for them that I cannot even
imagine.
A little one heads your way with a gift.
Oh, thank you.
Thanks for the gift.
Wait, I think I accidentally stepped on... Wait, I I like
heard his death cry from beyond the grave.
He was like, I think I stepped on his mind.
He did a death call from beyond.
Okay, where do I find these pheromones then?
Sorry for screaming.
How is the audio, by the way?
Let me know if I need to...
okay anyway oh we're out actually we'll do the electric yeah
someone just come in here
yeah oh I sound like one so when I take damage I go oh my
god wait that's so funny oh my god where are these guys
coming from they just don't stop spawn in at this point.
Oh, it's broken!
No!
Who broke it?
Who broke my health station?
Okay, I'm guessing we have to do something in the backup
generator then, is my assumption.
Please scream more.
Okay, hold on.
Unless it's just the safe.
There is also a camera in there.
This seems terrible.
I don't want to go in here.
Wait, this is how I got caught before, remember.
A minke chooses an eyebrow vase.
You now?
What?
Baby shark, do do do do do do do do do Baby shark.
If I turn the generator off, does it turn the camera off?
No.
I don't think there's anything in there.
I think it's just the safe.
Okay, let's... That's fine.
Actually, I think we're done with this area.
I think we can go to the other area now.
Right?
I forgot that there's a whole other side.
I forgot there's a whole other side to this establishment.
Shut up.
Oh, thanks.
Awesome, thanks.
Oh, that was close.
Save the game.
Wait, wait.
Baby whale.
Oh, it wasn't a shark.
It was a whale.
you oh
yeah it's become so tedious now too that i'm like oh man i
have the heck again it's not so fun anymore come on get oh
shoot um i clicked out of the game so i could figure out
what i'm the heck i'm doing can i one okay this one two
I don't have an up one, though.
Let's see.
Oh, shoot.
Uh, you?
Oh, my God.
I really do sound just like it.
That's, like, big daddy.
That's craziness.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, it's already there.
Please, please, please, please.
Oh, my gosh.
It goes so fast now.
Bup, bup, bup, bup, bup.
No!
I didn't have it anyway.
Big meenthal.
I have to hack.
It's what I must do.
I must hack.
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Wait.
This is possible.
This is doable.
Please.
No, I don't have the peace.
No!
I don't have the peace.
I didn't have the peace.
Uh.
Oh my god.
I don't think I have the peace again.
I do not.
I don't have the peace.
Wait.
Oh gosh.
Don't kill me.
Don't kill me, players.
Oh.
up ease yes finally oh oh my gosh you scared me thank you
tonic collector collector invent 53 tonics in the physical
engineer wow nice i got an achievement prolific inventor
inventing is already a valuable pastime in the resource
strapped halls of rapture make yourself a prolific inventor
and you'll be the envy of your peers as you turn worthless
junk into valuable commodities
That sounds exciting.
Blip-bloop.
A child.
Bye.
Oh my gosh, you're villain.
Thank you!
You got me through my unemployment, so this is an I- There
is no such thing as an I-O-U.
Recently, especially Peak Nostalgia with Bioshock and Alan
Wake.
With a quick squeaky window.
Awesome, thank you, villain, thank you!
Wait, that means, though, that you got a job.
There's no such thing as IOU.
No such thing.
I think we gotta get some hacking things, you guys.
You know, I always forget that I can actually destroy the
turrets myself, but I don't want to do that.
I don't want to do that.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's see.
What can we grab?
There is Winter Blast!
I have not used at all.
Okay, hold on.
Wait.
Before we do anything, just save the game.
The thrill of the hack.
Same, I always felt like, what if they're useful later?
Exactly!
Right!
Hello?
1948 wait what was the passcode for that one guy's thing i
can't remember now all of a sudden wait you can also buy it
wait this is this is a this is impossible oh no this is
impossible stupid ass game
the sun's also impossible 1921 thank you
oh it's me i'm making the noise I forgot.
I sound like that now.
I sound...
It might be risky having it as a thing, but...
Uh...
And then, over one...
noise.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
In the garden we are growing little girls give me presents
one less type of tile tonic that is true maybe I should do a
plasmid slot oh shoot I did a plasmid slot
I meant the engineering sl-
It's fine!
Well, we can get the winter blast!
That's always exciting!
You're kind of rich, it's okay?
Yeah, I think it's okay.
Security- wait.
Wait, what did I just put in there?
Trick the security system.
Set security boss and turrets on your enemy.
Oh, that's right!
There is technically that.
what i meant the engineering slur look at that actually i
think we probably have like so many that oh wait i can't it
won't let me put it in right now though shoot shoot shoot
shoot greatly reduces the prices of vending machines
that's so funny um she's just clicking button who's in
control here no it's fine actually i kind of want though i
kind of want the winter blast you know so i think maybe i
could buy it and i'm pretty i'm pretty sure we can have
something once we find another gene whatever the thing is
that allows you to switch your plasmids and stuff off we can
just put in something there for uh winter blast also slows
down hacking yeah that would be huge for like the safes no
let's grab it i think it's okay i think it's fine if
anything just remember 720.
our save today from 7 7 20 p.m was pre pre mistake all right
let's what what's what do you got Oh!
Suit control system!
Wait, do I need that?
That sounds important.
What am I getting any?
After Ryan picks this place, here is where they build their
filthy golems and Frankenstein.
Find the pieces of the suit.
Guide them.
Guide the little ones.
I get to control the little sisters!
No way.
Is there a...
Okay.
Man-Hall.
I had a feeling you were still...
Ouch.
Oh, oops.
He's dead.
It's fine.
No, please.
What's that?
Thing that I need?
Am I moaning in groups?
I don't think I'm the one moaning and groaning.
Oh wait, I can't.
I can't use this yet.
Oh, security bots disabled.
Wait, I could have a little army of them.
Ha!
I don't even think that's my tummy.
I just ate.
I got a sacrificial taco.
okay once again i am safe scumming for the hacks i can't
winter blast because i i couldn't equip it i do not have it
equipped yet unfortunately um can i yes this oh no no no
that's not what i need oh shoot oh shoot shit no oh shit no
oh shit um
Does this work?
Oh my god.
I don't think it works, guys.
Team, I think we messed up.
Moni, groani, minto, phantomi.
Hi!
Team, yeah, run it back.
Maybe we just...
Just don't do it.
Guys!
You guys are so blind!
The bot shutdown was right here!
You could have saved yourselves so much trouble.
Trouble.
I'll eat that.
I don't know where I got the potato chips at all.
Wait, what if I robbed them of their batteries and pistols?
Nice.
Sometimes he forgets which pills are which.
Candidate induction.
Find the pieces of a big daddy suit.
Let's go!
Hi, wife.
Hope you're feeling better.
Mwah!
I am...
Ish.
A little bit.
Suit assembly.
Oh, shoot.
Like, you can't see me, right?
How do you see me?
I was invisible.
Maybe I wasn't invisible.
You want me to teach you how to...
Duh.
I'm waiting to see if anybody walks by.
Hey, hi.
He saw you.
He didn't.
He saw you shoot him.
There's no way.
Big daddy walking around.
This is where you find the bodysuit.
Okay.
Oh, big daddy bodysuit gives you...
You should be thanking me.
Shut up.
Something tells me that you'll need it.
25% resistance out all day.
Okay.
What?
That is good.
We will make disgusting Frankenstein out of you yet.
There is helmet and pair of boots and we will be, how you
say, in the business.
Nice.
Is he calling a little sister out?
I think there, oh yeah, I think this was, there was still
one more.
So, give me cash.
wait so what do i look like now i wonder right like how how
do i look oh my gosh we filled up all the point prometheus's
i wish i could find a thing that would let me change my oh
man it's over it's so fast I could change my...
It's fine for now.
We'll leave it alone for now.
Whoa, oh, sorry.
Oh, bad.
Can I go?
Oh, I can go down here.
Interesting.
Thank you.
Wait, is this the...
Oh, I think this is...
Oh, sorry.
19... 21?
Yeah!
Oh, hell yeah.
Wait, what do these do?
Control consoles.
Oh.
Whoa.
I don't need any of that.
Holy loot.
Yeah, seriously.
Napalm.
My napalm.
Everybody.
I don't need that.
Dang, really?
The armor piercing?
awesome let's see what this does then oh what do you do oh
oh it turns off certain why it turns off this oh
why do i why did i turn it off Would you kindly be beautiful
and cute?
Oh, wait!
You already are!
What if...
What if, like...
You asked of that of me.
And it's like...
I can't.
What do you want me to do?
Go get plastic surgery right now?
What would I do?
You go get more hideous?
More, hideous?
More than I already am?
Wait, can I go in here now then or sometimes?
Oh, shoot.
Excuse me.
Sorry.
Wow.
Secret.
That's how you'd get in without hacker code.
but I could only turn off the fire in here yeah what kind of
assembly line is this it just goes to here maybe it's not an
assembly line maybe this is someone's closet and it like is
really fancy you know
this is what I look like now in my onesie yeah All right.
Weren't you looking for boots or something?
Yeah, but I don't think they're here.
No, don't move.
Where'd he go?
He sounded mad.
Randru.
We all make choices.
Buddy me in.
Someone is really hacking up in something there.
Alright.
What is down here, anyway?
Whoa!
Holy cow!
Oops, that's not what I meant to press.
F1 is what I meant to press.
Where'd he go?
Oh.
Oh, he's dead.
Eh.
I meant to press F1, not one.
came out of the closet.
Wouldn't be my first time.
To be fair, Big Daddy's closet does kind of sound like it
would be a mall clothing chain in Rapture.
Right.
Oh, what's here?
Oh, more napalm.
Oh, what did I do?
Okay.
Oh, please be careful.
Oh my goodness gracious.
This looks like a door.
Something.
Hmm.
Oh shoot, I'm trying to shoot you.
Ouch!
Oh, because I did the electric buck!
Oh my god.
My bad.
Oh, stop, please.
Okay.
It's unsanitary in here.
Oh.
Is there more than one, you think?
Uh-oh.
Did I walk into a trap?
Wait.
Uh-oh.
I didn't save.
Wait, that sounds bad.
Getting a pedicure while watching Min-Tao Best Day Ever.
Oh my gosh!
Enjoy!
Relax!
Oh shit.
This is...
I wish...
just remind us to have her too.
No, I'm having a great time.
I'm having a great time.
Everything's fine.
Rapture is awesome.
Oh, see, we're fine.
What am I?
Uh-oh, I think there's another one that's attacking me.
I don't know from where, though.
Maybe we're fine.
I don't know what Fontaine was be apping about.
Save?
Yeah, we'll save.
You okay, Minto?
Yeah.
I'm having a... I kid.
I'm having a great time.
Just more threats.
He's such a kidder.
Wait!
Isn't this like one of those amusement park rides where they
strap you in and then you like start flipping up sideways
and upside down and everywhere what is going on in here
actually
the gyro ride yeah yeah yeah strap me in strap me in please
you think this guy's alive he looks alive
maybe he's not alive says corpse You never know, though.
Alright.
Any of these guys could still be alive.
Oh.
Um.
I don't know if I'm supposed to be.
Huh.
I think I know where she is.
I hope...
Oh shoot.
Wait, can I take a picture of you?
Heya!
Oh, that's it!
Oh shoot.
She's fine.
Nice.
Delicious.
Take your cash.
Find pieces of big daddy suit.
I'm working on it.
on it a pick with straight fire oh so now okay cheap son of
a bitch Fontaine scary son of a bitch but Ryan cheap son of
a bitch you can no reuse protector suit take a man graft the
skin and organs straight into suit otherwise your suit will
not work Ryan's a big daddy too expensive Ryan can go suck
an egg.
The Circus of Values!
Another one?
She sounds so close.
Where is she?
Whatever, I don't care.
Please turn off.
I think that's the only one I need to turn off, though.
Wait, why isn't he talking to me, the Circus of Values?
Why aren't you giving me the whole spiel?
Please.
I need to hear it.
Okay, just say that.
Graft into the suit is like crazy to hear.
Just take their skin and like, you know, easy.
Easy peasy it.
Nice.
Just like this machine.
I need your clown, your voice clown.
Yo.
He's not giving...
Oh, here it is.
Yay!
The Circus of Values!
I guess I don't really need anything.
I'll buy a first aid kit.
Just for funsies.
Okay.
So now we go back in there.
Country Road.
See, I keep thinking she's about to sing Country Roads.
She sounds like, she's like, take me home.
What's in here?
Wait, why can't I get in here?
I was able to, but cool.
Quick!
Automatic.
I'm gonna show you what it's like to look different.
You want to look funny?
You want to know how I got these scars?
You want to look funny, kid?
That was it?
That was all that was in here?
Automatic hack?
I mean, that's great.
I love automatic hack, but...
Sounded like Jesse Pinkman?
I've seen people adding Walter White to their Tomodachi Life
Islands.
I kind of want to do it too.
I want Walter White on my island.
Oh, shoot.
I tried to take pictures.
Oh.
No!
What do you mean he's mostly out of frame?
Alright, well, uh...
Let's just set him on fire then.
there he goes is he coming down Walter what's up there
anyway how do I get up there oh shoot nice
oh that's how I get oh excuse me oh dang it just had some
alcohol I think a big daddy's on his way here that guy's
alive Now he's dying.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Tom.
Tom, too much, too much, too much.
I can't hold my liquor.
Jesse Pickman.
Protect.
Oh, I think so.
Did I just scream you big, daddy?
Oh, you're real.
Make a terrible stink.
Very smelly.
Maybe something can be done.
Little sisters seem to like Odwa.
Now we have to find the recruits.
Ouch.
It's a one-way street.
But Ryan says, don't worry.
Recruits will be no problem.
He's a good guy.
I wanted to listen.
I couldn't really pay attention.
The issue with these kinds of when you're like fighting for
your life and like also.
I haven't
are you coming?
Oh, are you up here?
Wait, is that a swapper?
Yes, it's a gene bank!
Oh, fuck!
Finally.
Oh, thank goodness!
Okay, we can get rid of... Oh, shoot.
We can get rid of this one, and we can get the winter blast.
Oh my god, as you can see, my cursors.
Okay, there we Yes!
Stinky Vagdadi, get some ectoplasm perfume.
Stop it!
Everybody should be decked out in ectoplasm perfume.
Alright, now we can choose another engineering tonic.
Oh, it already put one in!
It put in Focus Hacker.
Two fewer overload tiles when hacking.
Oh, maybe that's good then.
Maybe that's kind of all I need.
Four fewer alarm tiles?
Wait, no.
because we it's either two or four right yeah uh two fewer
overload i think the four would be better probably smells
like minto in here
but they stack well what's the other one that i have uh oh
two fewer alarm tiles and two fewer overload yeah so we want
to probably keep that hacking expert too what did i do oh
the clever inventor um oh also since we have this already
shorten alarms we'll just choose shorten alarms too which i
feel like whenever i have an alarm i just reload so i'm not
even gonna keep this
um i realize that every time i set off an alarm i i reload
so i'm just gonna get rid of the sad save scummer and i'm
proud especially for this game let's see when you whatever
whenever you invent an item you get twice as many as normal
wait that's insane what's this one inventing requires one
viewer of each component hmm reduces difficulty when hacking
safes and combo locks maybe we'll do the safe wait what's
hacking it's Oh, this one.
What is this?
What's this one?
Wait.
Oh, the two-fielder.
And hacking expert alone isn't enough.
You need hacking expert too.
Maybe this is better.
Just take upgrades for hacking so you don't have to reload.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
This should be fine then.
Probably.
Yeah, I think that'll be good.
Okay, we're gonna grab this cache and then we'll save.
Yeah, okay, save my choices.
Oh my god, please.
Ah, it's because my mouse is so crazy.
Oh, they're down there.
Oh my gosh, we have such a good view.
Oh, they're, wait.
You didn't destroy my...
I think he's stuck.
You know where you're going?
How can I see how many...
Okay, there's a couple areas we haven't been to yet.
Little wonders.
Optimize eugenics.
Oh, mistakes.
Could I have made mistakes?
One does not build cities if one is guided by doubt.
But can one govern in absolute certainty?
I know that my beliefs have elevated me just as I know that
the things I have rejected would have destroyed me but the
city it's collapsing before my have I become so convinced by
my own beliefs that I have stopped seeing the truth Atlas is
out there and he aims to destroy me and to destroy my city
to question is to surrender who the hell is making that
noise back there
oh she was drinking them up that's it that was her i think
she's having a big old gulp
wait so then now if i like run up and do this oh shoot i was
i was too late
Oh, oh shoot, I'm not doing enough.
I don't think I'm doing enough damage.
Oh, there we go.
Slorp.
I'm ready for dream time, Mr. B.
Mr. B.
Oh, she's ready for dream time, you guys.
You kind of fell into doing that with the wrench.
Ah, close enough.
I don't know what...
is shooting.
Shooting and shotin', there we go.
Not the scabby.
We're still searching for...
Um...
I do like it though.
That was fun to...
to blow her up.
Hooting and hollering.
Wait, what's this here?
Protecting little ones.
Every
man in my city, except for Su Chong.
Su Chong have opium.
Very good opium.
Opium?
This war is a terrible thing too, but not for Su Chong.
Everyone's scared now.
Everyone needs Adam.
More than little sisters can make.
Good news is war makes lots of corpses.
Su Chong knows a way to recycle Adam from corpses, but can't
send the little sister out to street unprotected.
That's why the big daddies were made!
No way.
All right.
I still have to become big daddy.
No active goal.
That's a lie.
I don't know.
Let's just keep running around, I guess.
Let's just keep running around.
Or something.
I'm already a dad.
Oh, we're up here.
Where does this go to?
Oh!
Did I go this way?
Guardian Conversion A?
No!
This is new.
Oh.
I turned tail if I were you, kid.
Ain't nothing here for you but tears.
Why is the music all...
Why is the music all funky?
If something's shooting at me, I can't tell.
It seems like it, but I don't know from where.
Maybe not.
Beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep.
That person's not dead.
Maybe they were dead.
How very arena shapes.
Don't say that!
I guess there's nobody in here though.
I'm looking around.
What is this even for?
You're right, though.
It is very arena-shaped now, isn't it?
All right, before we grab head.
Hackers Delight 3!
This will make every hacker a healthy hacker.
Wow, big lava lamp.
Oh, no, wait.
Hackers Delight 2!
Every time you hack something, you gain...
large amount.
So now I have gained even more, right?
I'm gaining the most just probably.
Wait, can I get the other helmet instead?
Can I change my mind?
Do I need to go in there?
Probably not.
Can I get...
I want the other helmet.
I don't want this one.
Yeah, no Mr. Bubbles helmet.
No, I don't want this one.
You have to be rosy because the bouncers are drill arm only.
Okay, I'm over it.
Oh!
Oh, look at you.
You look just the same as those.
Now, what things you have done?
What things?
Now the boots.
My hearing is like even...
Oh, I'm...
I'm looking through all fish islands!
Yeah, we just need the boots.
What about my... what about my hands?
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Ah, uh...
Okay.
Shouldn't you leave me alone because like I look just like
those things now?
Oh shoot, I didn't mean to do that.
I just want to talk to somebody.
Oh, you're dead.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Get a cool shot of you?
Nice.
Ouch.
Uh, I'm meant to do this.
A little ambush now, huh?
Oh, where did I go?
Oh, there he is.
I could have handled that better, maybe.
But that's fine.
My, like, my hoodie, or not my hoodie, my, my thing gets
messy even.
Like my, oh, hi.
Yo, you're not gonna come in?
Okay.
Alright, now, uh, I guess we go back to the manhaw?
Oh, that does...
Wait, did that say main hall this whole time?
Oh, it's a decontamination.
Two years already.
Think about there, too!
In the garden, we are growing.
Now, I'm guessing it's probably in there.
What am I hearing?
There's a whole lot of noise going.
Oh!
I have I have eagle high vision did you guys see that I saw
that from all the way over there
my little cardigan sleeves that guy is alive right there
I can
see you
Oh no he's not he is not alive I almost got him though what
did I do anyway I think oh gosh I have to be like the
fastest ever all right hold on to save she hates being on
fire I like how she briefly talked ship before continuing to
burn right she was like oh you monster i could save you okay
i'm so fast i'm so fast wait where's my third thing that i
got didn't i get a third thing oh shoot didn't i get a third
thing am i crazy to think that i got a third thing
We're doing this all crazy like that's fine though
Gotta go fast I did I went fast which one is it f6 okay f5
is fire
I feel like I want to go back and
I Saw that though that right there Grab
Do they think I'm Big Daddy now?
Do they think I'm Big Daddy?
He's still shooting at me, though.
Oh, he's dead.
Let's see.
Where do we want to go?
There's so much in this area.
Whoa!
There's so... Whoa!
Oh, there's a first aid kit.
I just saw it.
Where is she?
Oh, she's like in her bedroom.
Can I take a picture of you?
Can I get her?
What?
Oh, it worked!
Nice.
Houdini.
Oh, it's the Houdini.
Respect her privacy.
Yeah, I'm missing boots.
I
got the pheromone, but hold on, before we do that.
Where'd she go?
I think she's dead.
Dang, they die really fast now.
Am I like... do I got the... I got the daddy upgrade or
something.
Ouch!
She's right there!
The... Ouch!
Ouch!
The big daddy buff.
Yeah, wait, let's see.
I know why it has to be children, but why just girls?
This I cannot determine why, but I know it is so.
Fontaine says, ah, one less bathroom to build since you were
finished.
Ah, the hidey hole.
It's amazing to watch the effect of Adam on their small
bodies.
Their own cells replaced by the new stems the instant they
are damaged.
These children are practically invulnerable.
It is a shame you could not do the same thing to an adult.
There would be quite a market for a man you could not kill.
I don't need that.
I am, like, trying to look around a little bit before I...
Just decide to grab the pheromones, you know?
Let's go downstairs.
I don't know why I've been avoiding it this whole time.
Oh, whoo-hoo-hoo!
Wait, is that in there?
I...
I don't...
Oh shoot, come on.
Eek!
Yep!
Oh
gosh, okay.
Bye-bye.
Give me what I need.
Thank you.
Uh...
Yes, that one.
Is what I wanted.
There we go.
Actually, do I have what I need?
I don't think so.
Wait.
I'm cheating.
No, I messed up.
Wait, can I fix this?
No!
I missed it.
That was my bad.
I could have saved it, and I didn't realize until it was too
late.
No.
another
one yes and then up and then over over to the right over to
the right you gotta be heckin kidding me again rigged from
this door it's fine I'll just use a health kit when I can oh
shoot oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh Oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, I need a long boy!
I need another long boy!
Oh my god, oh, I'm panicking.
Erma.
Nice.
Oh.
And to the right.
To the right.
To the right?
Shh.
To the right.
No, I don't have one to the right!
To the left!
To the right!
Okay.
Uh...
Let's just do like that.
Um...
I wasn't sure how I could have saved it, so...
We just...
Oh my god, wait, no.
Wait, I need one that goes up.
Oh, I think the other guy woke up.
I think I might die if he shoots me, actually.
So not good news.
The opposite, actually.
I think we might be in trouble.
Wait, upies, upies!
Ah!
Where am I?
Wow!
It's just a load.
No upies.
Oh, I'm here!
Oh my gosh!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
probably.
Oh my gosh, I didn't even think about it.
A streamer didn't save scum.
After she's been safe scumming this entire time.
How mysterious indeed.
How peculiar.
Well, I don't feel like doing it quite again yet.
Maybe we'll go down there first.
You know?
Here.
So mysterious.
Why do they revive you and nobody else?
The Vita chambers?
They explain that, actually, I'm pretty sure.
Wait.
cute oh shoot not back eyes oh my bad see the babies come
out covered in death oh shoot what's so funny is you guys
don't see this oh shoot but i've been like rearranging you
know how like you have all your i have my task bar at the
top and like all my little windows and stuff i've been
rearranging them this entire stream they're like all over
the place right now
it's coded to ryan andrew ryan's dna yes yes or anyone that
shares it with him yeah that was what it was i do remember
that there was a lore reason you're not gonna come in here
though okay good i want to see look at this guy
angel oh that's why she calls them angels oh my gosh is that
big daddy that's so cute
he's a mama okay we know where the pheromones are oh oh be
careful be careful be careful be careful are you the one
that took my baby okay please uh uh uh shoot uh shoot uh is
it again working there we go Baby!
Thanks for the read!
Thank you!
We're playing, um, BioShot.
Oh shoot, why did I do that?
I'm being an ultimate hacker.
And my game is a little scuffed sometimes, so I apologize.
Hello everybody!
We're like towards the end of the game though, so maybe...
Ah!
Spoilers.
Paperbacks, thank you!
CC, thank you!
What did I miss?
There I go, thank you!
We're a single choice thank you!
I can't see you too, thank you!
You have a taskbar at the top?
Yeah, I just, that's how I've always had it.
Ducky, thank you!
That's just how I've always had it, you know?
It's one of my little peculiarities, okay?
Oh, I forgot that was there.
Holy cow.
Oh, this doesn't open.
I could open these.
Okay, hold on.
Let's go back up.
We can, like, see into all of them, which is kind of fun.
Actually, anything that I want, I could do.
just like telekinesis grab.
Yoink.
Like we went in there.
I don't want the cigarettes.
Don't give me that.
Ah!
I forgot about her.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
Holy cow!
Ow.
Um.
Please.
I need a different gun.
I do take like way less damage now though.
It's kind of crazy.
Thank you.
Thank you bees.
Is there anything in there?
Can't tell what that is.
Jump scare.
I know she actually jump scared me.
That's pretty gruesome.
And we know this lady's in here.
Or in this one?
The other one?
You?
Nice.
There's more pheromone in there.
Wait!
That's a present.
Okay, let's go back down.
Be careful, though.
We'll go back down.
Wait, there's a circus of values right here.
Nobody told me.
me it's because he's he's so shy now oh hello we'll go the
other way he's so shy now he doesn't say anything to me
oh wait they're like right in front oh
she likes getting adam i prefer the minke value i'd have all
the values i'd have the best values
Oh shoot.
Oops.
Okay, I know I just saved, but we'll do it again.
All right.
Okay.
Everything's fine.
Oops.
And then you.
Great.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Are they behind me?
They didn't walk in here, did they?
Truly Fontaine's more dire and devious plot, turning off the
clown voice.
Because you don't know!
Then you...
Wait, did he actually do that?
Did he turn it off so that I would never know when the
Circus of Values is around?
Evil.
Dubious.
It actually might be his worst thing that he's done yet.
Yeah.
I don't care about deceiving me.
And...
Oh my gosh.
Wow, this is like a lifesaver.
Can you come out?
Or, like, leave?
Oh, this is where her thing is.
That's why.
Yeah, go to sleep.
Or something.
Can you leave?
Can you leave, please?
Can you go?
he doesn't want you to have value he doesn't want me to save
money that's what he doesn't want
oh i should what she said something something's dancing in
her all right
no i thought it was dang i like someone's practicing their
anime i over here what the hell always stay close to a
friend you
are a corpse and they're a corpse of the money but and use
what does that do button use I press
the women and she gave me chips I pressed the ban and he
gave me chips.
It's a potato chip dispenser.
Free chips?
Another circus of values.
Alright, I guess we should get the pheromone now, huh?
Wait, what's happening?
Wait, why is this?
why is the music all bad what did i do ah game stop please
game stop please please please it's opening up new windows
oh shoot i need another long boy oh good good good uh oh my
gosh all of our new things help so much it's so good
Everything went freaky.
Oh, he's just chilling in here for some reason.
She's a hacking machine now.
I feel like I'm reborn.
I'm back, baby.
I had a moment of weakness, but now everything's great.
Fantastic.
Boy, it's happening.
Oh, it's one of these things.
Safecracker 2 Wait, I just got, I just attached Safecracker
If your enemy is trying to lock away what's rightfully yours
Don't let them get the Keep your hard earned goods Get them
back with new Safecracker 2 Hack Smart, what's it to get
What's coming to you?
What happened?
Oh
Actually, I'm not sure what happened at all Who are they
attacking?
Oh, this guy.
I think he took care of him.
Some poor chap walked in here, yeah.
I wonder.
Should we try?
Should we try and take this guy out?
We don't need to, but
him oh he's so close oh that was close though like i almost
ran out of grenades dang
easy yeah so easy now probably could have used like some
other bullets there three out of three gatherers you're
welcome thank you Dang, he's got so much...
No!
I can't take all his bread in here!
Wait!
Circus of...
Values!
My values!
We'll just go hack it real quick.
Wait, uh, we'll go buy one.
Alright, this is fine.
Surely they'll have such good stuff that like, we will be...
Oh shoot.
Oh.
good I need oh what just happened wait what actually just
happened I'm lazy I said I was reborn but I lied I'm a big
I'm a fraud I'm a fraud
all right let's Get our pheromones.
Oh, I need three!
I need three!
I need three.
Why the little ones are drawn to the smell of those
pheromones?
It's beyond anything I can understand.
I really enjoy watching your streams.
I can't wait to attend Densit's first lady live this summer.
I turned 22 today!
I was wondering if you could wish me a happy birthday.
For a glorious puppy birthday!
Happy birthday!
And see you!
in July!
Thank you!
So exciting.
No one's laughing at you, buddy.
Okay, easy.
Good.
I hear the squawk of the voice box.
I can only imagine how you must smell with those.
Why do they have these around?
Oh, our boots!
Our boots!
Where are the boots?
Wait.
I thought that's... I forgot about the boots.
I thought that's why we came in here for.
Wait, now I don't remember.
Thank you.
Thank you for the love!
Thank you so much for the gift and thank you!
Really
got her hooks into you.
You can knock Ryan all you want.
But the old man was bingo on one point of fact.
You won't even walk till somebody says go.
Oh my goodness.
I don't know.
I'm just doing my thing.
He's hating on me for playing the game.
You won't even walk till someone says go.
oh the fact that like our blood comes out when we do that
wait so where are the boots then where have i not here i
guess where is that downstairs
boots are with the fur with the fur got the hook of the
Unless it's in here?
Mendel Memorial Library?
Oh, this is not a place that I...
No, no I did not.
No, you did not see me.
The game is...
They wouldn't be in the library, would they?
They are.
What are the boots doing in there for?
I'm hacking?
I forgot to save.
Actually, let's just...
Oh my gosh, please.
Okay.
Why are you doing that?
Why are you doing all that work?
There we go.
We didn't even need to save.
You don't take your shoes off at the library?
Maybe I do.
I don't know the last time I went to a library.
Maybe I do do that.
Freezing them is a massive buff.
Honestly, I'm kind of mad.
that I didn't do it sooner you know oh my god
oh shoot I did do it it's okay if it messes up we we can
reload this one because I just saved oh yeah please I have
to like go up and around I think up up up I can't go up and
around I can't It's all over.
Here, I'm going to overload.
Electric and freeze are very similar in that they both let
you hack and they both stun enemies.
Freeze is just better at hacking and electric lets you get
loot from enemies.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I am understanding.
Okay.
Maybe you're like this.
And can we get a little like this?
And a little like that.
Very good.
And then a long boy and boo.
Wow, it makes it great.
I mean, I know I just got some upgrades as well, but like,
holy cow.
Like it feels like, it really does feel so different.
I know it said that there was like a staircase here.
Or rather on the...
No way, those are the boots right there, aren't they?
No heckin' way!
What am I here?
Save since we just...
Oh wait, we'll save on this one.
It makes the hacking game fair again mostly.
I know, right?
The difference in liquid flow is very nice.
Yeah, it's crazy.
Let's go around here a little bit.
Oh.
Yes.
Yes, please.
Let's see.
is a bit of a little bit of a mage
can i have one of the yes you and then you and then you you
boom when i feel like a big daddy for a night on the town
try light this perfume stank that's the scent that'll get
all the ladies running away i'm so good i'm i'm so curious
though what does the pheromone smell like because i mean i
don't know pheromone i feel just has like a certain
connotation like a sexy connotation you know like when
you're talking about i had a feeling she was alive anyway
like it just gasoline oh my gosh i love the smell of
gasoline no i mean it doesn't but okay no like when when
when the lady is just like oh my gosh okay i maybe i'm the
only one that has seen these ads but they're like there's
this perfume
And it's just, my man woke it off of me.
And I'm just like, what does it smell like though?
Guess, gonna guess not like marshmallows.
Like, does it just smell like body?
Like,
what does it smell like?
I just have to know.
They're like, oh, it's just, it's the pheromone perfume.
Smells like pizza.
Oh.
armpit sweat it might hit them where it hurts I think we're
okay
hello what what was all that for oh
I thought that never mind I thought it was like a hole or
something there's so many little things around I have to
watch the ground though.
Gotta make sure I don't run into any traps of the...
Idiot.
Oh, whoops, I was on it.
I didn't realize.
Oh.
I love the sound of those things except when they're coming
after me.
Oh, you can?
Wait, actually?
Wait, you can shave me?
Shake us!
I mean, she's such a, she is so full of shit.
You know what makes me not a big daddy though?
Is I don't stomp when I run around.
Maybe once I get the booties, I will be ready.
You know?
I'll be ready to stomp.
If...
I wear a big daddy eye.
Stomp, stomp, stomp.
I don't remember what I just did.
That's fine.
Big ol' stompers.
Okay!
Become a big daddy!
Now this is a big daddy.
Are you ready?
Now go to the little sister vent by the proving grounds.
What's the proving grounds?
now i've got the atom now you take that tin suits even half
enough to put the scare in me the proving grounds oh i get
an arrow thank goodness do you hear that it's happening jump
jump bump bump bump bump bump bump your life your family
they're a fairy tale kid no more real than something you
read about in the saturday
summon a little sister you need to bring them out of hiding
and then they'll let you in the door go with my wrench with
your wrench
no is this an escort mission oh please god no on the way Oh,
where are you going?
I'm not really...
I don't know what that means.
It's not very hard, okay.
Hello.
Let's go.
There she comes.
Oh.
My bad.
Yay!
Yeah, she's got the tiny little door.
Woohoo!
Aw, awkward co-worker interactions.
She didn't even say hi to me.
Why does my little sister not talk to me?
Wait, why did my little sister change hair colors?
Who are you?
Oh, shit.
She is talking to me.
Oh, she is talking to me!
Oh, she's a fat...
Okay, she's a runner, she's a trek star.
Wait.
Oh, okay.
We're running.
Okay.
I have no time to explore.
Time to go, Mr. B.
Okay.
I wish Mint was my big daddy.
Let me in.
Don't be a slowpoke, Mr. B.
Nope.
I'm not.
Wait, who's shooting at you?
What's happening down there?
Oh my god!
Sorry, my mic peaked like crazy.
Is he okay?
They died pantsless.
I'm Mr. Bubbles now, it's me.
You
up to that wife and child, bitch.
Oh, me poor Myra.
Baby, baby, Patricia.
Oh shoot.
I'm trying.
Out.
Oh my god.
Wait, he takes so much damage.
Please.
Wait, why isn't he dying?
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
What is happening?
Why is he so tanky?
all of a sudden what the hell is it gonna get are the are
the cameras gonna get mad at us I'm technically a big daddy
no so they shouldn't right don't be a slowpoke mr.
B angels don't wait for slow pokes you're not gonna get mad
at me Okay, cool.
Why are we walking?
Oh, you gotta eat this guy, right?
I'll take his money too.
Even though they are physically free of the news together,
Su-Chung's mental conditioning still holds them to their
terrible panic.
Or still such as me.
She's just yapping.
It won't trigger on the splice.
either unless you hack it okay we'll hack it then what is
happening what is going on well hold on let me save save
real quick since uh i guess we're at point prometheus now
the horde is that a horde what is happening oh my gosh is
that what that all i thought like she was having war
flashbacks but no it's a literal horde of people coming
through okay we got We gotta go.
Maybe?
It's time to get out of here.
Or...
We'll kill them or something.
I don't know.
Anyway.
That is indeed a horde.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my god.
Come on.
No!
Oh shoot, my girl's about to die.
Wait, my- I think my little sister died.
That's messed up!
You can just call for another one!
Oh no, wait, this is- oh my god.
Oh, okay.
Alright, let's also hack this real quick.
Oh shoot.
Oh, this is gonna be yucky, isn't it?
Just grab another lamb for the slaughter.
No!
I'm gonna protect my...
Okay, wait.
Wait, this is...
This is mean.
I'm gonna protect my little sister!
Can I have a...
There we go.
Thank you.
Well, shoot.
Well, now that this is hacked, it's okay, I think.
Maybe.
Um.
Oh.
So I'm not gonna...
Whoa.
Oh my gosh, outer wild!
I won't...
Um...
And I'll also set them on fire.
But I'm afraid that they might touch my little sister and
then also set her on fire.
You know what I mean?
But they were so tanky with the...
They will freeze them.
Do I have mines?
Wait!
Wait, what about a tripwire?
Oh, shoot.
Wait, uh...
Or I only have one trap.
No!
Wait.
Where'd it go?
Wait, where'd it go?
Um.
Freeze actually gives them a second health bar when you
freeze them.
Okay, that's what I was seeing.
Okay, got it.
Look at the jellyfish!
Wow.
Did it...
Oh, wait, there it is.
What is it doing?
Wait, why is it inside?
How the hell did this happen?
Um...
Guys?
Guys!
That's funny.
It's a pretty good magic trick, Minto.
Thank you!
I thought so too.
Okay, well we don't- we- uh, we have mines too.
Proximity mine.
We'll do like...
There.
I hope this is far enough.
Do they only come from that side?
You're protected if the fish attacks.
I don't want to put too close to...
They come from both sides.
Alright, well...
We'll go...
Oh, I can get her from here.
I will save again, I guess.
Come on!
So cute.
She's blonde again!
What does this say?
Oh.
Education is not allowed.
Alright.
You good?
That actually might...
This might be a good weapon, too, to use, maybe.
Liquid nitrogen.
I'll use the napalm.
she's so slow okay i'll save once she gets over there
because otherwise we're just gonna have to wait for her to
keep walking every single time here little tapy taps are so
cute though
take a picture of her nice
all right maybe like here okay all right
Why?
Why though?
Holy cow.
I won't let you hurt her.
Oh, okay, good.
Oh, come on.
You blew up both of them.
No!
I'm stuck on her.
Oh, she's done.
Wait, no!
Don't go that way, little sister!
Wait!
Stop!
She has her earphones on!
See what happens?
Again.
Maybe it's fine.
She's walking right into it.
Get behind me.
Oh my god!
Robot instead!
Find a vent and summon another little one.
Oh, I don't have to go through all of it again, right?
Oh my god.
Yeah, let's just reload anyway because we...
Holy cow.
Alright.
Yeah, we just saved.
It's fine.
You do?
Okay, um, one second.
Wait, one second.
No, no, please!
God, no!
Oh, she walked right through it.
She walked right through my bomb.
Is this thing gonna go off?
Easy peasy.
I'm scared.
Just super stealth skills.
There's a reason the section is legendarily excruciating.
I didn't know that.
Nobody told me.
We'll hack it anyway.
I just saved, so...
Oh my gosh.
Wait, please.
Oh, why did you open that window?
Please, stop it.
Oh my god.
Please.
Nice.
Braggvada looks different.
Oh, okay, so here's another one.
Okay, okay.
All right, save again, sorry.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I'm guessing this will be really nice to have, so we're just
gonna have that guy out.
Where did they
come from?
Where
did they come from?
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
Holy cow!
That's so funny.
Oh.
Are you on my side or...
Are we good?
Okay, we're good!
Okay.
We're fine probably.
okay oh oh we're shooting somebody stop running where did
she run to oh no they destroyed my thing where did she go he
has no money where oh my god please yes I think it's getting
worse one second mr.
B is searching around the proving ground oh my god oh my god
don't be a slow pole angel don't wait for slow pole uh maybe
I can freeze it or is it dead get a mr.
B hurry mr.
B even though I heard it too I did it.
I did it out of fear.
Wait, this is so icky.
Okay.
Alright.
Can we, um, yeah.
Actually, oh my gosh, freezing is so nice.
Please, please, please.
Okay.
It's so slow.
Just keep, just keep saving.
The lady said little sister are almost indestructible, but
they are so fragile.
Wait, right!
What is happening?
Hurry,
Mr. B.
Um.
Is this okay?
Uh, I don't think he likes us very much.
What's happening?
Why did that happen?
Oh, shit.
Sorry, I don't know why I'm cursing so much today.
Please, what did I just open?
No, exit.
There we go.
Where did she go?
Oh, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck because of you.
I'm stuck.
Time to go, Mr. B.
What was that?
Oh, it's another one.
nice please i can't take it anymore i seriously i can't take
it anymore i can't take it i can't take the cursor anymore
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no
I saved it.
Oh, okay.
What?
Hurry, hurry, Mr. Bubbles.
She was just gonna run over in front of it.
That's what she was about to do.
She was just like, yeah, I'll run in front of the turret.
How interesting would that be?
Wouldn't that be so fun?
She literally was just about to.
She was running over there and then stopped and was just
like, never mind, I changed my mind.
dancing I can't take it anymore I can't take the cursor
thing anymore I can't I can't do this anymore that's the
shock game experience okay we're doing good doing good shit
shit shit
oh yes oh my goodness oh the one piece that I needed the one
peace okay she's got me trapped again why why are we doing
this all right sorry I'm gonna keep saving because my cursor
is gonna it's gonna be the enemy last stream of this you're
almost there yeah come on let's go holy
Oh shit, uh...
She's gonna die, she's gonna die.
Never spliced up once the whole time I was down here in this
aquarium.
Figured it was bad.
Wait.
Mixed business with pleasure, but...
Forget all the nose candy and all the polish I don't waste
time with.
This stuff is the mother's milk!
The mother's milk!
and see the angels dancing in the sky okay save again oh my
god please let it be over the mother's milk wait do i have
anything that i can oh yeah oh yeah baby why yeah i should
have froze you first but that's okay oh oh oh oh oh one
second oh whoa how did you get all the way over Oh my
goodness.
Okay, hold on.
Let me rearrange some of my windows up here.
Since they're all funky.
No!
Okay.
That works too.
No, it doesn't.
Oh, gosh.
I need another.
Oh, please.
Please.
Let me play the game.
please oh i'm not gonna make it am i wait uh shoot yes i am
i am gonna make it i did it okay hold on oh please are those
spiders no they're crabs
what was i what did i use before this put us um
we'll just incinerate them Like that.
They'll just incinerate them.
Where'd she come from?
Oh, shoot.
No!
Yeah, kill him.
Maybe I should have hacked that thing over there, but it's
fine.
Yeah, she'll die.
She'll die.
It's fine.
Okay.
Oh, we're done.
Light them up.
Yeah, it's kind of awesome, actually.
We just set them all on fire.
We just keep setting them on fire.
It's fine.
Screen freezes on...
Did she die?
No.
Wait, did she die?
No, she's fine.
She stands literally right behind me.
Oh my god Wait what am I killing This guy?
Oh because I was like Don't be a slowpoke, Mr. B Okay Oh,
bud Let me loot a little bit, please Don't go, don't go far
Don't go far I love they're giving me all this cash And I
have nowhere to spend it She really is just On her...
She's on her way, she's...
What the hell?
How am I not getting this guy?
Okay, okay, we're going, we're going, we're going.
Where did she go?
Wait, where is she?
Oh my god!
Oh, he was in water.
No.
No!
Ah,
so proximity mine, I have none.
She's gonna die for sure.
But he won't kill her.
Yeah, it is time to go!
Holy.
Time to go, Mr. B!
Ah!
Holy cow!
Oh, I'm out.
Oh my god.
Better for the girls to be with you.
Better with you than alone.
Alone in the crawling darkness.
Oh, why is it on fire?
Did she walk through that?
Where is she?
Where did Vice...
Where did she go?
You tanked his head.
Yeah, we did.
Where'd she go?
Fontaine is nearby.
You are reaching close now.
I think...
There.
You must use the needle of the little sister to drain
Fontaine of his Adam.
Okay.
It is the only way to defeat him.
I don't know where she went.
I guess we do gotta go in here though.
She go into the vent.
She's...
She did good.
Oh, there she is!
Ah!
Hold, oh, wait, is this...
Okay, this definitely feels very final boss now, huh?
Okay, they're giving us literally everything that...
Oh, God.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
They're like...
Stick it in the bad man.
You bet, you bet, you bet.
Also, we did it!
Oh, my gosh.
We did it.
Let's go.
We did the...
escort mission with like 2 HP in a dream.
She almost died.
She really almost died.
But that's okay.
We made it somehow.
Uh, shoot.
Oh, that's not what...
No, that's good.
That's bad.
No, I'm gonna have to hack all...
Wait, is there not a circus of values?
Okay.
Hopefully this has auto hacks.
Dang it.
Can you freeze vending machines?
That's a great question.
I mean, I could invent them, but I have to hack it now.
I actually have to hack it now.
Does this have any more?
Oh, there was one there.
Dang.
What do you mean I can't carry any more napalm?
Oh, dang.
There were first aid kits right here.
I missed two of them.
Whatever.
There we go.
What do you mean?
What am I waiting for?
I'm working on it.
Wow, they give you nothing here too.
That's crazy.
We can get a physical tonic slot and then...
Or we can do health upgrade.
Eve upgrade.
And then they're like, I hope you bought everything.
else that you wanted.
maybe we should get like a physical slot or a combat slot.
I can get both.
Hold on.
Let me save again.
Please.
Okay.
There we go.
Smoke him if he got time yeah so it's kind of like buy
everything you know wait let's oh okay let's see if we can
invent a auto hack let's see if it'll this one's just so
tricky oh my gosh oh my gosh wait you know what this is fine
we're gonna get the we're gonna get the other um what's it
called the other health kit oh my gosh so fast though please
um oh my god it's so fast let me see if i can
i don't think that did anything no no it's so fast
If I don't get, like, exactly what I need, exactly when I
need it, I'm screwed.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, no!
I thought it was a...
I thought it was up.
No!
What are you waiting for?
Okay.
Please, please, please, please.
There we go.
Oh, it's too fast.
Too fast.
This one is insane!
It's so crazy.
I don't want to buy it out.
You guys, I don't know why you guys are freaking out.
This has literally been my strat this entire, like...
You can't...
You don't die to the hacking.
See?
Even though I have no health.
That's why I was saying I'll use the first aid kit.
And then I can literally pick up another one for free.
That's what I was saying.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I don't know why everyone's like, you have to heal,
you have to heal.
Yeah, guys, okay?
It's just a tough one.
Which I, honestly, I'm like, can I even do this?
It's so fast.
It's so, oh my god.
Wait.
Oh, there's no way.
I don't know if I can do this.
Unless I get, like, the ultimate luckiest ever pole ever,
ever, ever.
Um...
No!
It's not that I need the discount.
You know what?
That is kind of big though.
Oh wait, why did I do that?
I didn't mean to click it twice.
Oops, my bad.
Oh well, whatever.
Whatever!
It's fine.
I don't know what I need for him
Unless I was gonna say Oh I have too many What do you mean I
have a heat seeking RPG already Um I'm getting all flustered
Because my game keeps The game with the game Keeps acting
stinky It gets me all flustered Sorry guys I don't know if i
need any more armor piercing okay let's buy these uh
physical stop please and uh combat okay all right close now
we go to the gene bank what did we put in here this one
branch damage No.
No, no, no, no.
When you...
No, no, no.
You're gone.
Thank you.
Take damage from cold and you can freeze enemies when you...
When you hit them with a wrench.
I guess maybe the static discharge would be best.
Inferno?
more damage when you use fire actually yeah that's better i
forgot and then though this one what did we do here first
aids also give you eve that sounds good move and swing
wrench uh first aid kids give you more health yeah i i do
use fire three let's do the eve link
We'll do e-blink.
What it gave us before.
Stick it in the bad man.
So true.
Oh, I didn't even look at there.
And then heal and then grab.
I think this is all.
I think this is all we can do.
Maybe.
Right now.
I don't know if I need to save before after.
Probably after is fine, but whatever.
Last save.
Oh, okay,
okay.
They gave me a second chance.
No, I think we're good.
I think we're good.
No, my heat seeking are preaching.
Just sit and ignore the lives of Atlas and his parasites.
Confront Fontaine!
Oh my god, we're doing it!
Oh,
oh, I didn't mean to do that.
Oh my gosh.
Let's go!
If you want to backtrack, if you missed any little sisters,
now is the time.
It's okay.
I think I- I mean, not I think.
I know I missed a couple, but that's okay.
I'd rather not.
Thank you so much, bro.
Oh, good, good, good!
I remember when me and the crowd Put you in that sub What if
I go back down?
You were no more than two You were my ace in the hole But
you were also The closest thing I ever had To a son And
that's why this hurts Betrayal kid Life ain't strictly
business Whoa Fontaine You got this me don't thank you is
that him up is that him right there oh of course it is find
Fontaine
Fontaine oh oh my bad sorry uh I'm draining your items
Holy cow!
Oh my god.
Oh, I don't think he's...
I don't think fire really does anything to him.
Holy!
Ow.
I missed.
Turn around.
Wait, what?
I'm draining?
Guys, it's so loud.
Ah, cool!
Shoot.
Oh my god, no way.
Ow!
Oh, please!
Leave me alone.
Ooh!
Ouch.
Where are they?
Eh.
Come on!
Where are they?
Oh.
You think I'm alone in this world?
Whoa!
What the hell was that?
Oh my god.
Ah!
Oh my god!
It's just chaos!
I like how she's cheering me on.
It's so cute.
Oh my god.
Wait, where the hell is he?
I think I should change weapons.
Where'd he go?
Catch my breath.
And I'm going to bury your little eggs Oh space too I had
you built I sent you topside I called you back showed you
what you was What you was capable of Even that life you
thought you had that was something I dreamed up and I
tattooed inside your head Nope I know what is Oh, oh, yeah,
yeah!
Drain him!
Yeah!
Get him!
Oh my god, oh my god, they're just like blank expression
like, holy cow.
Wait, there's no phase two?
It was that easy?
I felt like I was hyping that up for nothing.
Complete the game without heart.
Harvesting any little sisters.
What's that?
They offered you this city.
Oh, that's the key to the city.
Oh, my God.
Look at my little cardigan.
And you refused it.
And what did you do instead?
What I've come to expect of you.
You saved them.
You gave them the one thing that was stolen from them.
They've never seen the sun.
A chance.
Oh, the blood.
A chance to learn.
No, they're in debt now.
Oh my god.
To live.
Wow.
And since the end, what was your reward?
Does that mean?
You never said.
But I think I know.
My children!
Oh my god, my children.
So many children.
An education.
I have to say.
just realized my I had like my headset turned up because I
was trying to listen for like some fine tuning stuff and so
it probably was so loud in my ears but not for you guys I'm
so sorry I think let's race thank you so much for the 10
gift make me cry every time yay
flantane was so easy
volume was fine on our end okay that's good though amazing
mission complete see that there is why you're the best of
eyes the one and only we save the children i'm so curious
what the ending is if you harvest the children it'll be a
big daddy man congrats meinto congratulations thank you
thank you They were hacking games more difficult than that,
God.
We just styled on him over and over again.
Oh.
Oh, that was so fun!
Whoa!
Oh my gosh, I finally played and beat Bioshock.
I was always so scared to play this game because I thought
it was like a horror game, you know.
Which it is spooky, but like...
I don't know.
when i loved horror games but i could only watch people play
them and now i am the person playing them thank you guys so
much for those different times oh thank you so much for the
thank you big thanks to putting up with the giant with oh
with the game fighting you all the entire way that was
probably the that was the toughest part about it and you
know what it didn't act up a single time for the final boss
fight isn't that crazy big boss and her child soldiers She
really was all talk.
Congrats on finishing the game.
Thank you.
You're pretty good.
Hold on.
I want to read some of the other super chats before they
disappear.
How did you pay for their college, Minto?
I mean, I looted a lot of bodies.
Killing the villain easier than babysitting a single child.
The real boss fight was the escort mission along the way as
usual.
Descore missions.
Congratulations on finishing the game.
Can you give us one final?
Bees.
Oh, I'm glad that it didn't act up for the last boss,
though.
I'm sorry that it gave me so much trouble the entire game,
My stinking cursor up here.
Oh.
Thank you for playing my favorite game.
Thank you, Lord Wahoo.
The sequel is a weaker story, but the gunplay is more
refined.
fine and they took the escort mission and made it fine i
don't know about that it's an old port so it's all good
congrats on beating it thank you yeah i took so much money
from corpses system shock 2 waits for you in a dark corner
of steam watching waiting taunting oh that reminds me would
you kindly play bioshock too i'll think about that i've I
think I probably will play Bioshock too.
But that reminds me that Control is on super sale.
It's like 90% off or something on Steam right now.
I just bought it for two bucks.
I got it.
And like the whole Alan Wake collection is on sale too.
So.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So if you are uh also wanting to play alan wake and control
and all that then uh it's on crazy sale right now
good stream i had this in the background doing something
else thank you thank you get in the lake alan yeah be a
reminder to play alan wake too chat i guess though steam
doesn't have alan wake too huh I did buy it on... I did buy
the collection on Steam because I had Alan Wake on...
Uh... Epic Store?
And it also came with Alan Wake's Nightmare if I ever get an
itching to play that.
Which I probably won't, but...
Congrats again for beating my favorite game of all time!
Glad I stayed up for this before I work tomorrow.
Good night, Tilda the Adam Slugs bite!
Good night, OCD!
Jai-Hab Robot Man!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Yeah.
Epic exclusive, unfortunately.
Yeah, for Alan Wake, too.
That Alan Wake 1 DLC was something after all.
That was...
That was a slog.
I'm not gonna lie.
Yeah, I probably will continue Bioshock.
It's so funny.
I got a Bioshock TikTok yesterday.
And I was like, no way.
I think they are listening to me.
I've never gotten a Bioshock TikTok before.
But it was like a reference to Bioshock Infinite.
Dutchie, thank you so much for the 20 gifts.
Thank you.
They're listening.
Freaky.
TikTok.
Is Infinite good?
Infinite has a great story.
That was...
Wait, now we can go into the museum for real, right?
Thematically dicey.
Orphan concepts.
Oh my god!
Wait, I like it.
Oh.
Early bouncer.
Oh wow!
Wait, I like this concept a lot though.
It looks almost medieval.
Forest concept art.
I mean, we did have the garden.
The gatherer?
It may be hard to imagine that this creature whose job was
to reclaim Adam from corpses around rapture was the earliest
iteration of the idea behind the little sister.
Ew.
Look at his teeth!
Someone was just like, you know what would be more annoying?
A little sister.
Wait, there's like some crazy designs in here.
Pray Yam-ham.
Yam-ham.
Splicer.
Ew.
Early splicer.
Oh.
Ranged.
aggressor stitchy the first place or that irrational created
for bioshock stitchy was used in many early concept demos
and was fully functional in game with kinematics kinematics
gatherer the ultimate moey blob taking moey blob literally
hanging sea life not as much as a cut concept as an easter
egg for observant museum visitors these sea creatures can be
seen swimming past the during the Bathysphere ride down to
Rapture in Bioshock's opening sequence.
Cool.
Whoa.
Oh, he is cool.
Oh,
early Big Daddy concept.
Wow, I love it.
These are the early concepts for the Rosie type.
I love it.
Big.
spear splicer.
Ew.
She loves it.
I'd love to see those things go to school and get married at
the end of the game like the little sister.
Well.
Who are you?
The hooker!
Get around the same time as Stitchy and the grenadier.
This splicer was dubbed the hooker because of her wet...
Her?
Okay, but in the concept art, she looks hot.
It's because we could see the corset butter I think maybe.
Hooker?
I hardly even know her.
Neptune's bounty concept art.
Wow these are so cool.
The bodies floating in the ocean were cut late in
development.
When their cast shadows proved too distracting from the
action in the room.
Oh I see them in the...
Wow!
Oh there were gonna be bodies floating in the water?
That's insane.
Big daddy.
Sub-Bacon.
Oh, that's where that guy's family died.
Wait a second.
Who was in there?
Was that?
Wait a second.
Yeah, his fake family.
Alice's family.
Wait a second.
Who was in there?
Probably no one.
Oh, yeah.
Moira.
Moira, my wife and my two kids.
Who are you?
Missing link model.
This character is essentially the missing link between the
grotesque early designs and the human splicers that appeared
in Bioshock.
This is the last bad model we did before moving on to what
actually went into the shipping game.
Oh.
I always thought of these as Scooby-Doo monsters because
they were too inhuman to invoke empathy no i get that i
think that they wow this guy is huge i think that they were
a good mix of like creepy human and like uh how do you say
experimental like plastic surgery gone wrong craziness that
you could tell that they were still human and everything you
know it would make more sense if it were like i don't know
something like a virus or something and that made them go
crazy, you know what I mean?
Genetic freak.
Yeah, the early designs look like Resident Evil.
Yeah, yeah, right?
Slime from Slug.
Blood on inside of glass ports.
Tarnished brass.
This was the fourth protector concept originally created
with an organic slug attached to it.
A model was started but never completed as the team narrowed
their focus to three and finally just two big daddy types.
Cool.
What the hell is this?
There were some...
These were some of the earliest pieces done for Bioshock way
back when Irrational was still working on SWAT 4.
The only concrete ideas at that point were the undersea city
and biological experimentation.
So early concepts focused on those themes.
Ew.
Whoa!
Oh, that's cool too.
These guys are humongous.
Dang.
You might want to get that checked out.
Yam hand model.
The character diversely called Yam Ham around irrational
games was the poster child of the conceptual phase that
preceded the decision to go with human enemies.
Or toes.
What is that?
Hanging cell.
I want to see, I wish there was like a prequel.
I want to see what Rapture looked like in its heyday and
like the descent into madness.
Uh-oh.
Well, hmm, what?
There's a novel about it.
There kind of is, but no spoilers.
Nobody say anything.
okay
iconic rapture concepts first image that really captured all
the visual elements that made bioshock bioshock a large view
of the ocean the aquatic lighting scene and the elegant art
deco design elements without these without this image
bioshock would have been a radically different beast really
oh yeah it is very bioshock I think I need, I think I've
been thinking this recently, but I kind of want to redo some
of my emotes and have a yawn emote.
I have a sleep emote, but I need a yawn.
I yawn too much.
More daddies.
This might be my favorite one.
Hmm, I like it a lot.
I can't stop.
I this one is nice because it's very similar to the big
daddy that we have but it's I like the big daddy with the
drill I'm a bigger fan of that cool I like the I also like
that outside is not water at all it's like just an image
it's so funny
hi how me though hope you're doing well thank you Brendan
you too hope you're doing well oh I guess I have to just go
to the main menu.
Those are industrial drills, but they don't look nearly as
cool.
You're right.
You're making me yard.
Don't say yard.
Cool.
Well, we beat it.
Oh my gosh, we beat Bioshock!
In the end, we were the baby.
So cool.
Such a cool concept.
I had so much fun.
I had a lot of fun.
The music was great.
The theming was great.
The atmosphere was great.
Thank you!
Bye, Yashakureya.
Oh, my God.
Oh my god, thank you so much, thank you so much, thank you
so much.
Oh my gosh, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
It's too much!
Thank you so much!
Happy birthday!
is there a japanese birthday song you just say you just go
you just say happy birthday it's just the same thing
wow sing the phantom pain song happy birthday
congratulations happy birthday was how you Happy birthday.
May your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
Can't wait to see you play Pragmata.
Yes, up tomorrow.
I play Pragmata.
We go from being one daddy to another.
Yeah.
but yeah I am going so I think this is my cue to head out
thank you so much for the peek thanks for the oh says whoa
says thanks for the stream and congrats on the wind Minto
even if you just recently became a big daddy you've always
been the biggest in our hearts feel feel totally better soon
and have a whale of a good night thank you actually my
headache was not so bad at all during stream so that's good
and my throat is okay ish so yeah we i powered through we
made it through there's a bonus here's a sock in the book
palmito is a free ghost she doesn't have to deal with the
bioshock curse or scuff anymore yeah the little girl reminds
me of you because how small you are diana
I can't, I've been trying to avoid like, I've been trying to
avoid like spoilers and stuff, you know, of, of Pragmata
because I want to see her fresh for the first time.
I want her cute little antics and such.
She's so cute.
Yeah.
Also, I call his big boss, big daddy in private.
Maybe.
The three episodes of Needy Girl Overdose are out now, but I
can't recognize your voice.
Can you give a hint, please?
Oh!
What do I should do, Ratchelong?
I don't know if I have time next week, but we can do one
later.
The week after, probably.
Okay, so I had two lines.
I had two lines First one was That was my first one I don't
know when they say I haven't watched it yet I wanted to save
it And then my second line was super I don't even know if
they kept it because Because Because it was I I don't know,
maybe it was too otaku-like.
But they were like, I was, I think I'm one of the otaku.
And I go, Choten-chan!
But like super otaku-voice-like.
So I didn't know if it was good.
I thought that was you!
Maybe now you can hear me.
In the Needy Girl Overdose anime.
If you let us know what episode they ended up in, we'll go,
look.
It's an interesting show so far.
I wanted to save watching it for a watchalong together.
I've been doing a little nutso about Pragmata because the
two main character VAs also play characters in Dinoblade,
and I can't unhear them.
I get it.
So are they Scottish, British?
Curious when are you going to update schedule?
Tomorrow?
At the start of the week, I have a new schedule.
Have you played any of the Borderlands games?
Mm-mm.
I have not.
This game always, Bioshock always made me think of Dead
Space.
I don't know why.
Dead Space but underwater.
I wonder if it's kind of similar in scares I see where you'd
get that same era right I didn't play dead space I was also
too scared dead space is a lot scarier yeah same vibe kind
of heavy suits similar color scheme right dead space is
spookier okay that's exciting I do want to play Dead Space
sometime.
System Shock is like Dead Space, and Bioshock is an ancestor
of System Shock.
Oh, I see, I see.
Dead Space 1 is scarier.
Dead Space 2 is more action.
Boo action.
Dead Space is the sillier Michael Bay version of System
Shock 2.
Sillier!
I'm slowly...
getting through my backlog of games that I was one, games
that I always wanted to play and I was either too scared or
couldn't afford the game.
So I forgot that this game is made by XSystem Shock Dev.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah.
Wasn't there a, there was a remake though of Dead Space, no?
Which would you which would you recommend the original or is
the remake any good going through the backlog we love to see
it yeah the remake is good
remake is pretty good okay i'm for when i do play it
i do think i have to call it here though because i'm out of
water my throat is starting to get sticky again good night
miito take care of you too thank you You kind of have to
play the remake.
OG doesn't run well.
Oh no!
Overall remake is good, but there are some changes that the
OG did better.
That typically seems to be the consensus of things, huh?
Let's go get some water and rest.
Thank you for the fun stream.
We did it.
We did it, team.
So happy.
Fontaine was nothing.
That guy was a weenie.
All I did was run around in zigzags.
Guy was like a stinking...
Like an alligator.
Good fight today, Vinto, headache.
Be gone.
Thank you.
Yeah, I do feel better.
Hmm, maybe streaming is the cure.
Fake me, thank you!
Therborn Ninja, thank you!
Remake of the original system shock with updated visuals out
now.
You might enjoy it if you keep exploring the shock games.
There's so many, like, game universes I'm involved in now.
Like, the Alan Wake world and...
Wait, is that it?
Well, I guess Bioshock.
I didn't do anything but yay we did it I always give you
guys credit for for the victories because they are here
cheering me on so to me I feel like oh yeah half life I was
like there's so many more it has to be ah his combat coming
up yeah I always get I always think that everything that And
so when I also fail, it's a failure on all of our parts.
And you should feel ashamed.
I'm terrible to stream in its Convai series.
I hope you'll be catching...
He'll be able to catch up to its Convai 8.
Yeah, I mean...
I don't know when it's coming out.
It hasn't said...
They haven't said, right?
But I have a little bit of catching up to do.
I don't know if I'll be able to do all of the games.
to 8.
I really want to replace 7.
But, like, it's a great training arc to get myself ready for
flight controls again.
The last time I played Ace Combat 7, off-stream, I would
just, like, play some of the missions to try and, like,
learn flight controls.
You know?
I'm not the best at it.
But an attempt will be made.
System Shock 2 is made by the same guy who did Bioshock.
It works as a standalone game.
Just FYI, if you want to chase the name high that Bioshock
has.
Ah, okay.
Thanks, Dan.
Playing Ace 5 at the moment?
You like it?
Flight controls are so tough.
I know!
If you cleared the game, you clearly were good enough.
Somehow!
I did beat it.
Somehow, I beat Ace Combat 7.
And, you know, I think, no matter how bad I am at a game, I
don't give up on it.
I eventually will beat it through my sheer determination and
stubbornness.
Determination and stubbornness.
skill.
Nah, stubbornness.
I mean, though, stubbornness is to be studied.
I think I am quite stubborn.
That's one of my...
How do you say?
Not like a... not a good point.
A negative point about me that I can recognize.
Maybe...
It's like stubbornness to a fault, perhaps.
I don't think it's a strength.
I think it's a weakness.
for sure because i can also get stubborn when people when
people make me angry like if i see a comment on a video that
tells me not to do something i'll be like well now i want to
do it more your stubbornness is a charm point double-edged
sword maybe I'm used to watching people get better at this
game That's how it works for me anyway Because I used to be
bad at Ace Combat Just like you Hey But actually probably I
am bad though I haven't played in a really long time Mint
stubborn She's a real stub No
Mint Don't not be Wait Don't Don't Not be stubborn So do be
stubborn Easy stubbornness or determination probably both
stubbornness can be both depends on what you use it for
right didn't you say a comment about anime as a kid made you
more into it well I mean some several things like that
happen my mom being like it's just a phase you will not like
Pokemon in a year's time okay man okay man I recently got
like a comment I was just like on one of my videos have you
tried flight sticks I do have one I have not tried it I'm
scared I got a comment on a video that was like can you stop
playing so many simulation games and I was like man I'm
gonna play retro rewind today so stubborn she can't move on
to the next life it's true
lightly pushes you into bloodborne hoping your stubbornness
carries you the rest of the one day i will work up to a
souls game but you might want to be careful with actually i
know i know vicky really wants to play i was i always
thought like game would be like this is going to sound so
bad but like once I'm ready to retire you know because it's
like they're just so they're just so as they are you know
what I mean
so I was going to say you might want to be careful
they aren't that bad to be honest really I just always hear
the worst of the worst but I know Vicky wants to play So
I'll probably, I'll break that rule for myself now.
Don't ever play Bloodboard, does.
But sometimes, but if I play it, it probably will mean
nothing now.
It was like back a long time ago, I thought this.
Fine, I take it back.
I'm retired and I don't play Souls games.
That's why I watch other people play them.
Yeah.
Dark Souls is beatable.
Okay, Souls Game off the menu.
you no no no that was a long time ago i thought that i think
now it's probably fine not probably it is fine
you can have nimi as your god that would be so fun i feel
like nimi's builds every time i watch her play those types
of games her builds end up being like insane like she's like
so overpowered Oh, I don't know.
Any flight games I didn't ace combat, I like.
I found them to be clunky.
That's why I don't like a Microsoft flight sim.
The only...
I could do this now.
I wanted to do a Microsoft flight sim that went from
someplace in America all the way to Japan.
And we just fly together.
Don't play Souls games, Vita.
Where I'd hate that.
She got a very good weapon in her playthrough.
I know.
She was like a wizard.
Why the hell not?
Well, when I first had this idea, it was back when I was in
heaven.
And perms for that game were just impossible for some
reason.
I tried a million times.
I just wanted to try it.
If you survive the absurdity of Bioshock, Cursor, Scuff, I
think you can handle souls without getting broken.
For some reason, Microsoft just never, never responded.
If anybody in the chat knows John Microsoft, can you ask him
why?
Barry ended up crushing Dark Souls 1 with just hitting
things really hard.
When did first Dark Souls come out?
He's my uncle.
I'll give him a call.
Okay, thank you.
Souls isn't so scary Dodge to a 45 degree angle And where
you are you learn Each enemy as you go It's great to become
Zen about loss It's a game that I truly wouldn't be able to
save Scum 2010s 2011 His way is combat is better because
it's easier Go diagonal VTuber Nimi did so well in her dark
souls playthrough I think she first tried plenty of boss
Wow!
Well, Nimi's a gamer.
She's a gamer.
The Souls boss fights are kind of like the harder fights in
DMC.
I mean, I did eventually beat that game too.
We eventually prevail.
I gave up asking John, Mike, or Slop why he did the stupid
shit about a decade.
Minto is a gamer too.
Thank you for thinking me of that way.
We are gamers.
Oh yeah.
Still impressed at how you handled Virgil and DMC3.
Yeah, but it was so...
I'm still so embarrassed by 4.
I'm still so embarrassed about the ending of 4.
Where I was...
I just like actually crashed out.
just the thing about souls don't be afraid to play like a
dirty bastard a lot of the difficulty comes from souls fans
being stupidly prideful really i haven't seen any streamer
get a handle on the rev mechanic i feel like i had it was
that i understood it and i just struggled to remember it,
you know?
Pick called normal mechanics cheating.
That's so funny.
I remember, but I loved watching your DMC playthrough.
I'm glad.
I wish I had better memories of it.
I think I was so embarrassed by that last playthrough that I
was like, it kind of tainted the series for me just a tad.
Because I had so much fun and, I mean, I know it's a genre
outside of what I'm used to.
But,
yeah, I don't know.
It just made me feel like, it made me feel like actually
stupid.
So it kind of made me feel like, oh man.
What, I did, because I didn't close out the series on a
high, it just felt so.
It feels bittersweet
memory.
I don't remember it that badly.
It was pretty bad.
to me at least to me at least to
be fair even Miyazaki from soft soft one is from though from
soft one says he used all the tools at his disposal to get
through the souls games he made ignore the community I don't
even know that was an issue at the community I don't even
know that people were about how you play the game I guess
they're just like if you don't use your your your brute soul
or no not soul if you don't your brute strength and skill
then it's not a win I mean there's always going to be people
like that with any kind of game though oh sweet summer me
though I'm very sheltered ace combat community is also the
same it's just how people are with games i think but if
you're enjoying a game why does it matter how you play i
think that's why you know when people get some people get
like a little like they scoff at story story mode uh
versions of games but sometimes you really just want to
enjoy a story of a game and if you want a challenge there's
always a mode for that too i think it's just so silly to
scoff at a mode that you wouldn't even pick anyway it
doesn't have anything to do with you oh easy mode imagine
you buy a game for fun not frustration oh my gosh I feel
like a lot of recent horror games have been so frustrating
like I'll watch a streamer play it and it's just like a lot
of like there was uh there was like a back rooms game that
came out i think it was like subliminal or something just
ignore folks that fun playing your way yeah i try subliminal
yeah yeah yeah a lot of people were looking forward to it
and then all i saw were people commenting on how frustrating
the puzzles were and like how fresh and like then you hear
that about poppy's playtime where it's frustrating as puzzle
and then uh chase scene and this and that
Hello, Minto.
Hi.
I just like torturing myself with hard modes.
And you know what?
Power to you.
I think this...
I don't play...
I don't play horror games at all.
Yeah, Backroom's movie.
I'm actually excited for it.
I want to go see you.
They got a bad gameplay out as long as possible.
Ugh.
Poppy's playtime is just not good in general.
It's not my cup of tea.
That's why you haven't ever seen me play it.
I know that sometimes those games become like streamer game
of the month.
And they're horror, so it's very easy to get people, you
know...
Oh, I gotta watch the streamer scream.
What happened to the mortuary movie?
I heard it was bad!
I didn't go see.
I heard it was bad.
Game difficulty gives me Goku brain.
I long for a good fight.
Oh, no.
I don't know why it was bad.
I was looking so forward to it because I heard that it had a
lot of practical effects and stuff in it.
It wasn't that bad.
It was super bad.
The two comments right next to each other.
As long as it isn't...
As long as it isn't Vegeta brain?
What?
You gonna turn me into a house husband?
Exit 8 was good?
Was it really?
Wait, I heard that guy is going around like subways.
The exit 8 man is going around like subways promoting the
movie in like New York and stuff.
any New Yorkers you can go see him and he gives you
something I'm pretty sure house husband don't I heard XAA
was really good really that's crazy because the concept for
it is like literally the barest of bones that's awesome
that's awesome we need more good video movie adaptations
because the track record is kind of the way of the house
husband he's yorking it yeah
we got iron lung no there's that street fighter movie people
think looks good it looks silly let's see what else there
has to be more than more than that uh
grand teresmo actually i didn't watch it
mario movies yeah i love the street fighter movie it's so
bad
did you see the avatar movie got leaked i did i feel bad for
the animators i didn't watch it So, if you watched, if you
watched the stream of Doki and I doing the, what was it, the
Rule 34, whatever, Wordle, I don't remember what it was
called.
You know that I know nothing about Avatar.
I don't know anything about Avatar.
That's a lie.
I know a little bit about the first series.
We gotta stop seeing Ayala.
What if they heard my plot, my subplot, and they decided to
make it into a movie?
Wait a second.
Can you wish my favorite?
Don't tell the others.
Brother mediocre monk of a lady.
Happy birthday.
He turned 26 Tuesday.
Mediocre monk.
I'm sorry.
I'm late for your birthday.
But, happy birthday!
The blue avatar or the bald avatar?
The bald, bald, bald, bald.
Oh my gosh, it's making me want to go on the blue avatar
ride at Disney again, though.
There's one at Animal Kingdom.
And I don't remember who told me.
It was either Ashton or Barry.
were like you know some people get turned on on this ride
and it's because you're like okay you're on a creature that
like it's like i don't know do people get turned on riding
horses because it was kind of the same thing actually now i
think about it it's like riding a horse you could like feel
it breathing
yes not this again What do you mean, not this again?
Have I ever ridden a horse?
Uh-uh.
Well, I think...
Okay.
Well, I did one time.
They had to put me on a horse because that was the only way
to give me to the medicine man that was in the desert to
cure me.
Must not have worked.
But I...
Speaking of movies, I can't believe you haven't watched
Wally.
Jay!
I watched Wally.
I watched Wally recently.
I...
I'll only say horseback archery was an experience.
I watched Wally.
Wally.
Eva.
I loved Wally.
It was so cute.
I heard Ace Combat A is also gonna have co-op.
So I'm curious who are you gonna invite to play the game
with.
If it's a kind of co-op where anybody can join, then I'll
invite everybody to play with me.
incredible boy it was really good it was so good it was so
good wait there was something oh it's a lot of it like the
robots in it the guy controlling the spaceship not the
captain but the robot controlling the spaceship was so
glados coded like I was like oh my gosh it's just glados Oh
my god, it's just glados.
Oh my god.
The wheel.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The steering wheel.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think she expected us to get the reference.
What reference?
About the horse?
No, that was a true experience.
When I was a wee wisp, something happened with me, right?
with my ectoplasm happen and um we were on family vacation
and uh uh uh had many many spiritual advisors and went to
many boost spittles and nothing helped i was gonna go blind
and then we met somebody and they were like i know a
medicine man but uh they could only but cars didn't go out
there they were so deep in the desert so we had to ride on
horseback to get there like actually oh yeah some people
haven't heard the story yes this is a real story i think you
might be a main character yeah the horse story is real
and it tasted disgusting it was like some sort of offering i
had to taste it and rub it on my eye and then i was cured
luckily they dealt with ghosts i mean as a medicine man so
he's all spiritualistic and stuff you know
yeah it worked
at that point my mom was kind of desperate she was like
anything kind of sick did you get i don't know i was i was
such a baby whisper baby ghost Baby's first haunting Yeah
That was my only time in Vegas
First and last time Haunting Vegas, baby
Who knows?
Maybe I caught something in Vegas The house always wins
The world still has lots of secrets Deep in the desert Well,
yeah, I mean, that was They were in the desert
The shaman cast This stays in Vegas
My favorite was going to the Uh, the Luxor.
It was so haunted.
Oh my gosh, being able to talk to the other ghost there was
like, wow!
Haunted, haunted hotel.
What happened to Vegas stays in Vegas?
I went to Vegas just before Off-Kai last year and got
deathly sick partway.
Foxplay, no!
Go to the medicine man.
Actually, well, I don't know.
He was like, literal prune.
when i saw him go to the medicine man's spirit that's kind
of rude he might still be alive i don't know though he was i
i you know you know when like some people are so old like
just the wrinkles overtake their face i found the luxor back
rooms the last time i went there no way the weird pyramid
hotel thingy yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
Luxor felt weird Probably because it's super haunted
Yeah, it's pretty cursed
I know a witch I might be able to go get him Go, go Yeah The
medicine man used the medicine on himself To gain
immortality That checks out That checks out Always something
between your family and sand Well, that's where the the sand
curse happened it was the same trip that's where it all
started a
lot happened a lot happened in that trip it's all connected
it is I'm shedding new lore on my mysterious story you have
Anakin levels of sand drama actually for For those that
don't know about the sand, basically, on the same trip, we
were being shown around by the people that took me to the
medicine man.
They were like, hey, by the way, don't touch anything.
This is sacred ground.
And what does my mom decide to do?
Take a little bottle and scoops up some sand and takes it
home, and then all
hell breaks loose.
And I've been cursed ever since.
Instant curse.
Yeah, yeah.
That'll do it.
And I asked my mom, I was like, do you still have that sand?
And she was like, nah, I think I threw it out.
Because I told her, I was like, don't you remember taking
that sand?
And they said, don't take that sand.
And then after that trip, everything bad in the world ever
happened to us.
She was like, now that you mention it.
Curse of Ra.
Did she steal before or after the medicine man?
I can't remember.
Thinking of moving to Nevada.
You recommend?
Oh, yeah.
Because if you get yourself in a pinch, there's always a
medicine man.
Can't wait for you to listen to some of the vocalist comment
songs that you can add them to the...
Yeah, me too!
Return the sad or suffering.
my curse sounds like a courage the cowardly dog episode
it was really the middle of nowhere
man and gosh man and gosh I watched something recently about
how courage the cowardly dog was like how did they explain
it they said that like courage the cowardly dog was like
experimental to kind of gauge how people would react to the
kind of content that it did because it was like so
experimental and strange for the time you know
you saw that too very surreal yeah very experimental for a
kids show I loved that show though I loved courage.
I still quote courage.
I love courage.
It's such a good show.
I remember watching the pilot episode like, OMG.
I didn't know this, but apparently they like even had ads in
like theaters and stuff.
They were so confident about...
I've never heard of a... Well, I mean like...
I guess there are ads for TV shows, but for like a Kids TV
show was so crazy.
They were very confident that the show was going to do well.
I thought I imagined those.
I didn't even know that they had them.
They got an ending, quote unquote, with the Scooby-Doo
crossover.
There was a Scooby-Doo crossover.
Billy and Mandy, we have Courage and Billy and Mandy were
goaded.
Why can't we have these so creepy, like, gothic shows?
anymore.
They were so good.
My favorite episode from Courage.
I'm trying to think.
Mr. Katz was... Yeah, Mr. Katz was great.
There's one that I have in my head, but I'm like...
I'm Moomin over your fave.
Sorry.
Don't be sorry.
I love Moomin.
There's like a 24-hour Moomin YouTube channel that I watch,
like, all the time.
wait hold on
it's gonna bother me now the naughty episode that guy was
crazy oh i love when muriel turns into a baby and she goes
more macaroni less cheese more cheese and more macaroni i
love that episode
My favorite was definitely the giant starfish episode.
I don't remember that one.
Less cheese.
More cheese.
Such a classic episode.
And then she goes, I hate macaroni and cheese.
Oh, it's funny because that's like one of the less creepy
ones.
Hmm.
There's so many, oh, I'm like looking through like
screenshots of episodes and I'm like, oh, that episode was
so good.
Oh, that episode was so good.
I have a sound clip stuck in my head of courage saying
strudel and I don't remember the episode.
Oh, no.
There was another episode I quote too where there was like a
guy, like an evil guy.
I mean, that's just...
that's just courage but um he has like a little rat sidekick
I think his like house moves or something but he would talk
to the rat and he would go rat rat give me a hug rat and
then the rat would go I like quoting that one too Courage's
computer is more advanced than chat I love the Courage's
computer.
Yeah, I was thinking of her too.
So good.
Such a good show.
Good show.
Spooky and goofy.
Love it.
It's been so long that since I watched Courage, I barely
remember it.
I remember that.
Or rather.
that even if I watched it now I would still be like this
show holds up I feel like it's that kind of show jolly good
show but I haven't watched it oh my gosh I'm like seeing
screenshots though and I'm like oh my gosh these like
repressed memories we're coming out more macaroni less chase
but guys i will call it here now because i am getting sleepy
and hungry because i'm thinking of macaroni thank you for
joining me for beating bioshock i had so much fun i really
appreciate all your help with it too reminding me of how to
play things and that speaking of dark souls uh vicky is
playing well she's she's yapping right now but she'll play
eventually give her like another hour or something so we
will raid into victoria roman we'll have it we have a
densetsu raid um raid train yippee Thank you guys so much!
I had so much fun!
And I hope you guys did too.
And I hope that you have a great rest of your weekend if I
don't see you.
But hopefully I see you tomorrow for Pragmata.
And I know it's a sponsored stream.
But it should still be really fun.
And I hope you still come.
Even if it's a sponsored stream.
Thank you!
Even if you don't watch, you could just have it on another
tab or something.
The numbers help a lot.
Thank you.
So I could get more opportunities and stuff in the future.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Otsumito, Otsumito.
Have a good day, have a good night, have a good time zone.
I'll hunt you later.
Otsumito!
Eat the nashai.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Would you kindly...
Have a good night.
Bye!